there is a suspected Chinese spy balloon
floating over Montana I walk into the
green room and Jack masobic standing
there with his phone out and he's like
did you see this they did a press
conference it's a Chinese spy balloon
I'm like wait what then he's like they
scrambled F-22 Raptors and I'm like what
the is going on so apparently we'll talk
about that lead story Joe Biden wanted
to shoot it down and then they told him
no because allegedly allegedly because
of the debris they were like no we can't
do it so uh then we were like did they
really scramble F-22 Raptors for this
and they did so uh I guess that's the
lead story we'll talk about that in
other news Democrats literally screamed
no like the meme when they removed Ilana
Omar from our committees and some even
cried it's just so so crazy so we'll
definitely talk about the political
space and then um okay I'm just gonna
I'm gonna go with this one this is a
weird story apparently the D.A has
confirmed they are investigating whether
uh the rumors that Tyree Nichols was
romantically involved with the ex-wife
of one of the cops so that's that
actually Newsweek reporting that that
actually might be it it might not be a
cop thing
getting another dude's wife or ex-wife
and then they got revenge on him or
something so yeah I don't I don't look
at me I don't know the story seems weird
but anyway we'll talk about it before we
get started head over to timcast.com
become a member to support our work
click that join us button and you can
support our work directly so this show
the work that I do over at youtube.com
timcast and all of our after our members
only shows will be available to you and
are supported of course I can't forget
project Veritas released another massive
story this one they were holding out on
us because this drop has the defieser
director saying crazy stuff he's saying
like they are mutating the virus
outright says they are doing it talks
about menstrual cycle stuff so you can
see that on the front page timcast.com
as a member you are supporting our
journalists and um we're also working on
cultural Endeavors this coffee shop
it's coming everything takes forever and
now we're hearing that the actual coffee
product which they told us like two
months ago would take seven days to set
up now they're saying six weeks or
something it's so annoying but I'm like
can we just put in a paper bag and slap
a label on it let's just get it going
but uh with your help we're gonna make
these cultural uh moves we're gonna have
physical space for people to hang out so
I'm really excited for that we're gonna
have a members only show coming up for
you at about 11 p.m tonight you don't
want to miss it so become a member at
timks.com smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share this
show with your friends joining us
tonight of course is Jack the sobik look
I'm going to tell you something right
now I'm not even going to introduce
myself that balloon should have been
blown Sky High the minute that it
crossed U.S airspace and every single
second that it hangs there is another
reminder of just how owned our
politicians our system our businesses
are by the Chinese Communist party they
should have lit it up that's that is on
this package on a balloon it's a Target
it's not a surveillance balloon it's a
trial balloon it is they're trying to
see what they can get through but let's
let's say it ends by the way they say
it's not the first time it's happened
Let's uh let's we'll get into that so
Jack vasovic thanks for hanging out
appreciate Tim Hannah Claire brimelow's
hanging out hi I'm Hannah Claire brimo
I'm a writer for timcast.com that's easy
I agree they should have blown that
thing up or at least now I'm thinking
they should capture it throw a big net
around and bring it down break it apart
look at what it actually is anyway let's
talk about it later on the show update
on bucko he got his first injection of
stem cells oh he got it got it today
resting comfortably in my room letting
his body heal so in two weeks we're
gonna go in for the next uh do they they
don't need to harvest any more stem
cells they keep exactly they have a they
have like this mother culture that they
will infinitely be able to make stem
cells forever now oh that's crazy yeah
and I found out this is funny I could
have apparently I could have taken him
10 minutes away to get the whole process
no I drove five hours to a New York City
for the Memories it was Wesley Aaron we
did it together cool man we all went
together yeah I'm glad but a shout out
to Hopewell Animal Hospital in New York
obviously you guys were fantastic
um and well I'll let you know more as it
comes up yeah let's get in we got search
pressing the buttons yo what's up
surge.com been uh fighting on Twitter
fighting the good fight it's been fun I
really am really tired of that site but
I'll be there for you guys uh I'm gonna
fix Ian's camera here so thank you all
right let's jump into this first story
we have this from The Daily Mail Chinese
spy balloon the size of three buses is
spotted floating over Montana for days
as U.S mobilizes F-22 Raptors to
intercept Biden wanted to shoot it down
but Pentagon advised him not to because
of falling debris they say defense
officials discuss shooting out of the
sky on Wednesday while it was above
Billings Montana but decided instead to
monitor it closely F-22 Raptors were
sent from Nellis Air Force Base in
southern Nevada but they did not engage
with the object now you got this picture
here of a tiny dot but we got you we got
you look at this thing it's got solar
panels that's like solar panels right
look at that so looking at is a
technology package those are sensors
yeah
um this is a trial balloon those are
sense like it's it's literally a spy
balloon right but I think the reason
they did it was to see what they can get
away with and they got away with a lot
they're getting away with whatever they
want this thing could be carrying what
if this was a bomb what if it was some
kind of weapon or what if hey what if it
causes Havana syndrome well of course
keep in mind that what they're doing is
they're also judging our response and
that's your point with the trial
balloons so they're going to see how
long did it take them to scramble
Fighters how long did it take for the
balloon to stay there before we
scrambled anything up uh what's the is
there a diplomatic response what's the
Diplomatic are they going to put
sanctions they're going to put tariffs
keep in mind that you have to look at
through at all of this through the lens
of Taiwan because we know that that will
be
potentially another military flash point
if we continue our escalation in well
they just they just went into high alert
right scrambling they started uh
mobilizing their their air defense they
just scrambled a couple of days ago yeah
because this has been happening since uh
really since Biden got in office
basically yo I think this this is a bad
sign if uh China's recently China
mobilized a bunch of jets and warships
and they've been escalating firing
Rockets over Taiwan Taiwan is now
mobilizing it defenses what if this spy
balloon is literally to track our
response to Taiwan and what they're
doing and they're trying to gather as
much information as possible well the
the Spy balloon itself and we have to go
into what what does America have in
Montana that could be interesting to the
CCP and I guarantee it's not just
Farmland by the way is it a four-letter
acronym um it is uh what which which I
can mean ICBM yes ICBM exactly so uh the
the Air Force Base that when you watch a
movie and you see the nuclear silos and
the nuclear missiles pop out one of the
the three Fields where we have them
about 150 nuclear long-range nuclear
tipped missiles the intercontinental
ballistic missiles that were within
range of China and these are not the
only ones but these are this is a key
component of the U.S nuclear Triad which
is located in Montana specifically
that's why I think we may have been on
here before once and I was talking you
were talking about which state would you
want to be if
um the U.S fell apart and I said well
Montana has nukes so you know yeah I'd
pick Montana it'd be one of the most
powerful countries in the world easily
U.S current military installations in
Montana we have three radar sites in
Carter County we have Fort William Henry
Harrison in Lewis and Clark County and
Maelstrom Air Force Base in Cascade so
maelstrom's the one that has it and and
so of course what they're going to be
doing is and and now it's also
interesting because of course you know
China has spy satellites the same way
that we have spy satellite so we have to
look at why are they using a balloon to
do this when obviously so during uh the
Cold War for example the USU had the um
the YouTube spy plane this was okay the
Dragon Lady so there was a a pilot who
was shot down at one point became a pow
situation he was eventually turned over
we had over flights they had over
flights but then that's largely turned
toward and we still do it but it's
largely torn towards a satellite game at
this point
um they're actually funny enough there
was a there was an episode of Rogan
recently where they were talking about
the NGA and I think it was with Tim
Dillon and each of them weren't really
sure what the NGA did it's well spy
satellites that's what the NDA does
National geospatial information agency
and so our intelligence agency and so
the Chinese have this this capability as
well signals imagery Etc so if you want
something that's that what you know
people looking at this as high but from
a a an intelligence collection from
platform this is actually low yeah I'm
wondering is it the kind of thing where
we have such high-tech uh surveillance
things that the low-tech stuff can get
through now like you know that kind of
thing where you have Radars but you
can't see the thing right in front of
your face like lidar maybe we talked
about I mean they could be they could be
mapping the nuclear silence you know
that famous story where they did like a
war game with the old guard and the new
guard and then the old guys won and
they're like how did you do it and
they're like we sent a motorcycle
Courier with the information so you
couldn't intercept it and I was like
that's the big deal what I'm what I'm
thinking about this balloon is what's
worrying to me let me know what you
think
if China's getting ready to attack the
and they know U.S the U.S will respond
to an attack on Taiwan then they're not
concerned like a criminal who is going
to rob a liquor store is not concerned
that he's breaking the law with guns
because he's planning on breaking the
law in whole if China's planning and
engaging in a military operation they
know will create conflict the U.S they
don't care if we get mad about a balloon
they want to know what we are mobilizing
and where now
it's kind of an interesting point that
you make because we know that they have
the balloon there we know that we send
f-22s up the question is is there
something that the US government isn't
telling us that China was also doing
that they were trying to check the track
the response to our silos
was there would there be a Cyber attack
of Taiwan would there be something that
may maybe not rise to the level of
kinetic
um like a blockade or a missile strike
and they were trying to test our
response to see if we went nuclear with
this but that being said this might be a
trial balloon right for when they do
launch their attack in Taiwan and
they're going to want to gauge our
response with these Air Force bases in
in Montana I've got a feeling they were
in Canada uh along with the Canadian
government's approval and it got blown
off course
I think that might be what happened well
I mean look they're currently Indiana so
basically Canada is but operating as a
CCP they're currently in the United
States with U.S government approval
yeah three days we could we should have
shot and I think everybody knows that if
that if president Trump were in there
we're in the white house I mean we would
have found out this thing because
something would have blown up in the sky
and then we would have gotten a tweet
saying something like I mean just
imagine the Tweet chairman she had burst
your bubble yeah so so yeah I mean we
have this absolutely gone the U.S state
department has reportedly summoned the
Chinese Ambassador over the Chinese spy
balloon which has been detected flying
over Northern Montana oh boy maybe
another strongly worded letter will come
next no no no no no no no a physical wag
of the finger to his face even worse
even they're really going to give it to
him
shaking in their boots remember when
Anthony blanken was talking to China and
they just told him shut up up so that
was in Anchorage Alaska yep and they
went up and and blinken went in there I
remember this because they they were
whenever you're you're holding one of
these Summits like this and he met with
young Jay Chou which is sort of the
interlocutor for for the CCP he he's the
former Chinese Minister of Foreign
Affairs but he's currently on the pilot
Borough and even though he's the foreign
minister he's sort of the point man for
when it comes to International Affairs
young nature and he just ate his lunch
he just completely ate his lunch and
Lincoln was saying we're going to set
the new normal with China and we're
going to establish the new norms and and
put this all right all of those messy
Trump years are going to behind us and
he basically told him that you're
nothing to us he treated him like he
treated him like a student like a little
boy almost like he was he basically just
said you have no power here you know the
old uh like Lord of the Rings he said
you're not are you're not you're not
negotiating from from a position of
power that's right the U.S has nothing
amazing you have nothing we have
everything and so every day and I just I
want people to look at this by balloon
and I want uh particularly older members
of the audience who remember the US
during the Cold War and remember our
response to uh the Cuban Missile Crisis
or our response to anything that that
had to do with a direct threat to the
American Homeland this would not have
been tolerated for even one second
during the Cold War but today we're told
oh it's not that big of a deal don't
worry about it I think they've done it a
few times already and you know this this
package doesn't even
it's not about the sensors that are on
this it's about the US response from a
political and a military obviously a
military being directed by the political
perspective that if we don't have the
political will to defend the Homeland
against any threat that just shows once
again that we are distracted we are
being worn thin in places like Eurasia
where we're currently flooding what
tanks money every single day
fighting Russia in this proxy war that
we're in with Russia and now China is
considering and Professor mircheimer has
talked about this China is considering
opening up what would essentially be for
us a second front and a two-front global
company like World War II We're not
gonna be able to handle it
uh meanwhile and it's not so Israel just
attacked Iran the other day too so I
mean how many fronts do you want this is
like going to be a legit World War it's
funny they talk about World War one and
two and it's like Europe World War II
you had Japan you know Imperial Japan
but it's kind of like that was its own
thing and there were some cons you know
there was obviously concern with with
the US and U.S expansion and stuff like
that so it was like World War but you
know large portions of the world weren't
actively involved that's why you have
first world second world third world Etc
but this one this time it's gearing up
to be what you know today is today is
the 80th anniversary of the end of
Stalingrad today wow 80 80 years ago
today the bloodiest conflict in human
history ended the surrender of the
German six Army the field Marshal paulus
became the highest ranking pow I think
in potentially all of of World War II
um when when he surrendered at
Stalingrad but you know two million
people civilians and Military died in
the span of five months the World War II
the it was air power you know know the
reason it wasn't on every on every piece
of soil is because the B-52s couldn't
reach or I guess was it to be was it the
B-52 at that point and the massive bomb
they saw like local range you know
Britain to Germany back or and then the
V2 Rockets Germany to Britain we didn't
now we have lasers from space we have
inner orbital bomb Strikers you know
there's nowhere is safe on earth now
well it's it's it's it's all about this
right this is exactly what they're
focused on because when when Putin gets
up there and says this isn't World War
II anymore and we have the ability to
strike anywhere on the planet uh that is
the reality of nuclear war and that's
why the Cold War stayed cold because
there's an interesting dichotomy where
obviously nuclear weapons are the most
powerful weapon that's ever been created
but they also have this this secondary
nature whereby in it creates for almost
a more peaceful War because more
peaceful world because if everyone has
the ability to destroy everyone else and
end all of a civilization it's like
every buddy standing in the world
holding hand grenade with the pin out
and your thumbs down so all right well
I'm not going to drop my hand grenade
you're not going to drop yours either
and then we're all just stuck that way
and then the what Pro what I know we
have to deal with each other trying to
like non-proliferation agreements we're
like Hey we're gonna deep break down all
our nuclear weapons but no one ever does
it is that the thing I mean why would
you
you put down your hand grenade right no
you put you put yours down like no let's
do it at the same time at the same time
he may or may not be building hand
grenades but let's just set our hand
grenades down right exactly and so and
so my point is it's it's not in any
country's strategic interest to do this
it much has been brought up of the fact
that Ukraine did have some of some
nuclear weapons uh at the fall of the
Soviet Union and that which were later
transported to Russia and now that's why
they don't have them during this
conflict well let's let's talk about
this story from a Daily Mail Putin
issues threat to U.S Vladimir says we
will deploy more than tanks and warns we
have friends on the American continent
apparently they're saying that he's he's
brought the nuclear football with him
the the Russian version of it and uh
he's making a direct threat to the
United States over we're sending these
tanks our German tanks are being sent to
Ukraine basically it's NATO it's all the
same thing and if they use depleted
uranium cores or something like or
uranium cores in general he will
consider that nuclear war so uh China
Russia how close are we you think well I
think I do think it's funny that um that
every once in a while if I if I tweet
something about hey you should have
emergency food or you know you should be
preparing or you should have a good
pillow to sleep on every night
um when you're when you're in the well
that's post-apocalyptic World buildings
are falling apart you're gonna wish you
had a good pillow you're gonna wish that
how could you keep how could you stay
awake at night and keep in mind that
just a couple of days ago a couple of
days ago Mike Lindell
prepared for this that out of nowhere
Mike Lindell has been working on a
secret project to design and just
dropped my pillow too is that why they
floated the balloon they're trying to
figure out they're trying they're trying
to they don't want it to just get to
Montana they want to get to Minnesota
right it's because they're trying to get
the secret technology ilano Mars clearly
involved this is why that when she got
kicked off the Chinese are responding to
her being kicked off because she was
supposed to be working in with the
pillow conspiracy working in conjunction
with the reverse vampires that they
wanted to steal the technology from my
pillow too that's the problem we can't
allow this Xi Jinping is sitting in an
office room with like all of his command
you know commanders and Generals and
they've got a bunch of my pillows and
he's like how how and he slams the table
my pillow
but no no go back to your point you're
saying when you tell people to get
emergency food take the stuff seriously
all right actually take it seriously and
then they call you crazy they call you
Tim foil and then you turn on the news
and and Putin's talking about nuke in
the United States and and Brussels and
London everything else uh China's got
spy balloons over Montana over nuclear
arsenals where we scrambled F-22 our
most advanced uh fifth generation
fighter but but you're crazy for wanting
some you know a little bit of extra food
supply for your family to have in the
garage I was warning everybody
you gotta buy chickens that's right you
gotta get you and now
it's funny so we normally have like 180
eggs just stacked on the counters
because we're getting like 30 per day
and then when the egg shortage hit one
day I come into the office the building
in the studio and I look in the kitchen
and they're all gone like I'm constantly
telling the people who work here like
guys take some bags with you because we
have we have too many you got to eat
them and like some are getting like two
weeks old
now I don't need to say anything
actually hit and people took those I
think they're coincided with Luke
Rutkowski leaving the office he may have
maybe we may not have taken a few weeks
didn't they say it was something to do
with the chicken feed no it was a few it
was over there
I've also heard Purina people were like
don't buy pure I don't wanna I don't
know if Purina is doing anything right
or wrong oh yeah there was something
about chicken for you right no there was
something about like there was a chicken
feed and it was like a central issue and
then that hurt a lot of chickens and
then they went down which led to supply
chains because chickens are great think
think about how bad our our country is
at this point when we're living through
the collapse of complex systems every
day and we we fail that just basic
maintenance of our supply chains and
pretty much everything where we can't
even do eggs anymore this can't even
handle eggs people watch so I just
finished watching 1883. have you seen it
I haven't seen it but and it's funny
because I know my wife is watching and
sweetheart you're the reason that we
haven't watched it yet but uh you should
watch it but I do I do want to I do but
just seeing people who are right so but
we're not gonna I'm not gonna I had to
introduce her to Chevy Chase first it's
it's like a year and a half two years
old already but I'm not gonna spoil
anything because some people may not
have seen it but there's just many
things that happen where you're like man
I can't believe they couldn't deal with
that problem it's like I'll give you an
example it's like oh I stubbed my toe is
it bleeding guess I'll die nowadays it's
like we have a ton of things you can do
we're not worried about infection we
wash it with soap usually fine you can
then maybe put antiseptic on it usually
fine like did they not they didn't even
put Whiskey on their wounds I guess they
did did they like some people did and
some people didn't I mean it wasn't
Universal knowledge like I'm listening
to this podcast well this is the Civil
War yeah right what issue I like some
whiskey on the wound he's good right it
sounds like a joke but like it would
actually work uh I'm listening to this
podcast about the Kennedy family and
just like about the children the race
whatever and they had one daughter who
was like severely mentally handicapped
the bottom eyes hurt and the podcasters
were Rosemary or Rosemary Eunice was is
super into this right now she's the one
who like cared for her and eventually
started the Special Olympics but the
podcast hosts these two girls who are
doing it were saying like
it seems obvious to us that we're like
don't let her get the lobotomy but at
the time fewer than 100 people had gone
through the surgery there's a chance it
was cutting edge they said it worked so
well and it's this crazy gamble which
did not work made her much worse was was
terrible in the end but like
this is this whole it's easier for us to
look back on 1883 or or these time
periods where it was all experimental
they didn't know how they're going to
see if they just needed to see I always
think about you know what is it what are
people going to say about the 2020s you
know 50 years from now 100 years from
now what are they going to go back and
say oh my gosh these these people kept
radioactive microwave ovens in their
homes they put food in them you know or
or self whatever it is yeah that they
look better you could have lived to be
200 years old here's this here's the
scary thing so watch watch 1883 watch
The Last of Us and there's a scene in
The Last of Us that is also very good
where they're Ellie and Joel are walking
down the street and then she's like they
see a crashed plane and she's like did
you used to ride in those and he's like
yeah and she goes wow that's so cool you
got to go in the sky and just and seem
like it at the time and that's that's
that's the main point with all this
stuff this threat of War people need to
realize what makes it possible for us to
if I got two monitors right in front of
me we have TV up on the wall I have no I
could never make one of these in my
entire life if someone came to me and
said I will give you a billion dollars
make a TV I'd be like
I guess I buy glass and plastic I don't
metal how I'm not gonna be able to make
this it's crazy you need all of the
people and all the different Specialties
so as infrastructure starts collapsing
or if War really does kick off there's
going to be little things that you once
thought were so were so stupid and
mundane you're gonna be begging for and
that's why I've often said when we're
talking about this or Civil War
otherwise think about something that's
extremely common and useful in your
house but also extremely difficult to
synthesize what do you think that is and
then buy it I was thinking is it maybe
mouthwash how hard is it to make it it's
not really that hard to make alcohol so
maybe not but I'm thinking like I don't
know anybody I know people who could
probably make alcohol you know like
whiskey or something you could figure it
out but like a harsher antiseptic like
you know what we have with uh with
mouthwash although whiskey probably
works but what do you what do you guys
think that is like so I'm doubling down
on soap I think so soap actually is
relatively easy to make yeah just upon a
five miles what's that just use saponify
oils hence the word soap sip on a fire
oils saponify oils okay
um what if you have children milk
uh formula shortage right like also made
this point where it was critical people
didn't understand that babies can't just
eat stuff well this is where you got
this maybe a nice big steak and I don't
know since I threw Tanya on the under
the bus a second ago I'll I'll do a
favor because she was tweeting about
that story where
um these these or this mother was trying
to you know brought her her baby into an
ER I figured exactly where it was and
the baby was completely malnourished she
said I don't understand I feed her milk
every day but it was almond milk and it
was almond milk and she said well yeah
because we're vegan since we're trying
to raise the baby vegan and and they
were like this Baby's it is in danger of
dying it's it's severely malnourished
you can't just make up these decisions I
mean there's a very specific set of
nutrients that especially uh young
children need yeah and especially with
that argument like if you're a vegan and
you're saying oh giving my kids cow's
milk is disrupting the cow's natural
system like you're not stopping the
cow's baby from drinking with milk why
would you stop your baby from drinking
milk you specifically produce for it
like it's it's illogical but it's just
so ideological in this this idea that
well we're vegan so nothing produced by
animals vitamins doesn't make any sense
where do you get your vitamin C
we get it from China yeah no joke that's
crazy you'd have to so I ordered Pirates
I think we ordered a bunch of buckets of
power vitamin C yeah they make it from
black mold wow that's really weird
yeah carrots you think so you said
carrots
um you'd need I mean if you guys have it
I actually live uh rose hips yeah I do
live on a on on a lake so we've got you
know we've got fish
you know we can fish have vitamin C in
it uh no but the official yeah so you
know you can at least and they've got a
vitamin B12 they've got a bunch of stuff
in there this is the crazy thing to me
watching 1883 they're like well we got
beef so we got we got food and I'm like
you just live off of beef fur that's it
you like what you don't need anything
like that's it that's crazy and they
think they have like small amounts of
like stuff that they had like preserved
beforehand right like for me I can't say
what substance I would like want to know
how to make but I just generally would
like to get better at like jarring
things or preserving food right because
if you can grow all kinds of fresh fruit
food that's great but if you can't make
it last the winter then come any kind of
Apocalypse you're done but keep in mind
Tim that that our society today as it
currently stands is the aberration what
we're talking about is the last 10 000
years of human history was exactly that
uh it was where are the plentiful
forests where I can go and Hunt game and
then obviously agriculture comes along
and and okay we're gonna we're gonna
have towns we're gonna have Society
we're gonna have civilization but when
you break when Society breaks down the
question is since we've become so
accustomed to living this type of life
that we have which is extremely
luxurious that we don't have the ability
to just just fend for ourselves
basically and I think with Last of Us
that's a great example you know you
mentioned that thing about the the plane
uh they see a plane crash right
and I I think about it when a couple
years ago I took my kids to Cape
Canaveral and I remember they have the
one of the last space shuttles I think
it's the Atlantis they have in the
warehouse there that you know it's in
the museum but you can go see it and I
remember thinking you know when I was a
kid we had spaceships and and we had
this thought particularly in the 90s
prior to 9 11 that it was going to be
spaceships and then the next thing was
going to be colonies and then we were
just going to keep pushing out for a
lunar Colony first and then Mars was
going to be next and we were just going
to keep going and this was our destiny
right this was this is the way we're
going to work on things now and that
somewhere along the line 9 11 happened
we decided to invade the Middle East
then we decided to debate more of them
at least that wasn't involved in 911
then further countries that had nothing
to do with the Middle East now we're in
Eurasia because we've always been at war
with Eurasia and we don't seem to have
ever gotten back to that basic idea of
human progress did you watch that video
that went viral recently on Twitter
where it's a high school workout in 1962
and all the young men are yeah like
basically in boot camp yeah they're
they're doing men they're they're
swinging from those bars on what they're
called like they're they're holding
their own body weight monkey bars it's
not monkey bars they're they're they're
they're vertical yeah they're vertical
wow Ian wow I really dropped the ball on
that one really just but man you can
stream man yeah we we open polls I I
don't I don't I don't know what happened
to this country but I kind of feel like
the night is always darkest before the
dawn and so as long as you are working
on being something or d-o-n
the note is always darkest before it
becomes orange before I mean that's
that's actually a really interesting
thing you just mentioned the dawn is
orange and so is the done that's right
and the night is always darkest for the
Don he comes back I'm just saying
whatever happens if you're
self-sufficient if you get out of the
Cities if you get some chickens and
maybe a couple goats or something you
will you'll be okay if you keep your
chicken Safe Keep Your Chickens safe
that's a big thing bro I'm telling you
it's gonna you like if if it really does
hit the fan and War breaks out I'm not
talking about infrastructure collapse
societal collapse I'm talking about the
US government saying we all have to
pitch into the war effort so we're
taking all of the copper we're taking
all this steel the the eggs are being
shipped off to the Troops so you're not
gonna have eggs you're gonna be eating
rice and beans if you're like red bread
they'll love this yeah they're gonna say
eat the bread eat corn they're gonna say
eat the corn victory garden and then
what's gonna happen is remember you're
gonna be you're gonna be sitting in your
in your in your living room and then
also you're gonna you're gonna hear
and you're gonna go what what you're
gonna run out and you're gonna go ma
something's getting the chickens and
it's gonna be a guy in a flannel shirt
with it with a handlebar mustache and
suspenders running while uh Peter and
John is playing and he's like I'm just
so hungry and you're gonna be like drop
my chicken it's gonna be and then
there's gonna be a bunch of other
hipsters running around with him yeah I
was gonna say it's the hipsters from the
city who are like these people are crazy
I don't need to leave my lifestyle I can
stay in my one bedroom apartment no
chickens for me they're gonna steal your
chicken try and eat it I saw a tweet
from Dash dobrovsky who I actually want
to like a lot I don't know him but it
said that's a work right that guy's not
serious I can't tell he is
instead of he's literally an actor like
a child actor yeah he's been on a bunch
of TV shows he was uh he his first
appearance I think was on Jay Leno so
his whole thing's a bit he might be
doing a character but he was a little
over the top for me but I I appreciate
his tweets I really like his tweets
usually I find it entertaining but the
Tweet today was or from yesterday men
who use guns aren't real men what the
hell is he talking about he's talking
about Ukraine he's basically saying that
he hates Ukraine and that anyone in
Ukraine is not a real man because they
shouldn't have guns they should be
surrendering to Russia it's it's maybe
it's a joke maybe it's hyperbolic
they're the force of their testosterone
would be able to to stop the Russian
artists like you you fight with your
hands yeah it's because he's not a real
personality he has he's uh so Nuance bro
actually did a big takedown on him
showing his IMDb track record like the
movies the TV shows he's been in the
things he's filmed it's a bit he's he's
he's a he's a cloud chaser I see I
wouldn't be surprised if he really did
doesn't truly believe everything he says
it's kind of a short-sighted state does
that mean Alec Baldwin isn't a real man
turns out let me let me let me give a
special shout out again I'm gonna give
it a special shout out to to Hassan and
his fans because when uh I I did a video
saying that Hassan was correct
about the cataract surgeries that's
interesting yeah that he was like this
fills me of the rage that we just don't
give these people these things and I was
like yeah I agree it's like we're
spending all this money on war and stuff
I think he missed something though when
when I said we spent a hundred billion
dollars on Ukraine right Hassan's
response was to start laughing and then
offer up no critique as to why what I
said was wrong and as fans all started
calling me stupid and they said before
that I was right but as soon as I said
don't support Ukraine with our money all
of a sudden I'm wrong these people are I
call them neocons
you know it's like neocon but communist
yeah I think there's a Comics
they want they're Communists but they
want foreign intervention and War but
you know what it so they're basically
like John Bolton and then Sean
probably get along really well I don't
think Hassan would want to solve the
Ukraine I don't think he wants War I
think he was pissed because you he
thinks that what you're doing is is
deferring to
um conservative agit prop as he refers
to it as like yeah the the blindness
thing is ridiculous that we're not
helping blind people but then when you
mention Ukraine he's like why are you
talking about conservative news
conservativeness just Ukraine in his
mind it's like a conservative he
literally says In that clip the
military-industrial complex is the
problem and we shouldn't be giving them
our money and that's literally what I
said a hundred billion dollars going
into Foreign Wars and countries that are
not on our border I think it was gender
Pakistani gender stuff
the starter pack of I'm I'm edgy but
it's okay to tweet these things and then
he agreed with me and says they're doing
that gender studies thing as a liberal
PR so he basically agrees with my points
but then rallies his followers to attack
because it's not real commentary real
commentary is when Hassan says I I'm
filled with rage Watson watching this Mr
Beast thing and then I say I see a lot
of people criticizing Hassan but I agree
with him that we're spending 100 billion
dollars over Season War that we spent 10
million on gender studies in Pakistan
when a single dollar of that could have
gone towards Medical Care in this
country he then agrees with those points
because he has to but then insults me
derides me and then rallies his
followers against me you start insulting
me because it's not real commentary real
commentary would be assessing the
political position
analyzing it and then either agreeing or
disagreeing and making making your
statement not just going
he thinks we should be at war in Ukraine
but anyway that's my point about
desperate dubrowsky and I want to go off
on but I do I do have an interesting
similar take to Hassan but I I think in
it it's it's more in line with what
you're saying that it's not just Ukraine
though because what you're dealing with
and I think what a lot of people are
dealing with with the response to Mr
Beast was cognitive uh dissonance was it
a classic textbook case of cognitive
dissonance because here comes a guy who
just fronts the money for this surgery
and is able to cure a thousand people's
blindness in seemingly overnight in an
instant whereas it costs about six
thousand dollars per surgery and think
about what we've been doing as a country
for the last three years it's been
crisis after crisis after crisis where
the media your favorite influencers your
uh your government officials are telling
you that you must care about the current
thing the current thing is the most
important thing in the world uh the
going thing they used to call it in the
UK that this must be dealt with and it
doesn't matter how much it cost whether
it be diversity and systemic racism
whether it be uh covid and we must we
must defeat Covenant we must have the
vaccine mandates it has to be this it
has to be done did anyone against us is
uh is is part of the problem and and of
course remember Biden given speeches
about this and now that that thing is
we're in Eurasia we've always been at
war in Eurasia it must be this and
suddenly so so there's that Moment of
clarity where it's like the Principal
Skinner meme right of am I out of touch
and then immediately it comes right back
that no it must be the children who are
wrong that's cognitive dissonance I want
to jump to this next story we got this
one from the Wall Street Journal rep
ilhan Omar ousted from foreign affairs
committee by GOP and uh you know I don't
really care if they removed her I agree
with Matt Gates when he said removing
her from her committee simply because
you don't like what she said is kind of
stupid but I think he voted to ouster
right he voted in line with the
Republicans is that what it was I think
I saw that everyone did yeah all the
Republicans were in favor and and I
think what he said was this is different
this is not just removing Schiff or
swallow from a committee this is putting
up to a vote and then you know the vote
of course succeeded but here's what I
want you to see
you guys ready to listen to this no
Democrats scream no
is on adoption of the resolution those
in favor say
aye
those in favor say no
opinion of
[Applause]
make it louder Play It Again
they're still going and without
objection the motion to reconsider is
laid on the table
those in favor say yay those in favor
say nay like and she's supposed to say
those against say no not those in favor
say yay those in favor say Tim I think
you got to play it again yeah I think
you got to Play It Again
those in favor say no
oh yeah that was against say no ladies
so wait wait basically she tricked them
so everyone yeah unanimous removal of
villain it depends on the text of the
motion
[Applause]
is on adoption of the resolution those
in favor say
aye
those in favor say no foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
conduct himself with dignity Lauren
bobert and Marge Taylor green heckling
during whatever oh right these are bad
like I'm sorry are you not up holding
yourself to the same conduct that you
apparently expected there's one more
isn't there uh I don't I don't have the
Cory Bush one pulled up no the AOC
you've got you got to have the AOC I
hope I hope that my friend Alex Stein
hasn't seen this it might put him in the
hospital uh when he sees the AOC video
today but let me address us something
very quickly right here because this is
called retaliation
the right here we didn't start this and
I I'd like to write distribution this is
retribution retribution and retaliation
we were putting points on the board and
this is something where if you saw
Jordan Peterson has this whole thing now
about oh we need to be careful that uh
you know the left doesn't use this kind
of I'm sorry have you seen the left
lately have you seen what they're doing
have you seen what they're doing to
Children guess what we we're going in
and we're going to use whatever tactics
necessary to correct the problem and if
there is a tactic that's already been
used against people on the right like
Marjorie Taylor green like they try to
do it but I don't even care I don't even
care who it is I don't care what they
said I don't care what they did we're
going to use it back tenfold until it
stops I get well do you think it'll make
it I don't know if it'll make it stop
though because it's like saying okay
nobody can hit anybody then the kid hits
the other kid and you're like oh and
then the kids like I want to hit him
well in some situations like you know
what yeah hit them back then no no you
got hit you can hit him back and then no
more hitting until the entire system is
corrected and this is the difference
between the new right and the old right
the old right will sit there and and
plain about oh but we're you know where
you know how dare we use those drop
boxes we shouldn't use drop boxes at all
and the new right would be like I want
dropboxes in the back of every Church in
the country yeah we had a Rex Santorum
on and he's like we can't impeach Joe
Biden we don't do that we're better and
I'm just laggling you lose you know
Rick Santorum was my first boss in
politics and uh I mean look nothing but
respect for rjs nothing but respect for
the senator nothing but respect for uh
for what he did and by the way being one
of the first people to say things like
it takes a family to raise a child not a
village not a socialist system
um but I do think yes at some point you
got to take the gloves off yeah yeah
yeah
um if you want to keep losing I get it I
can respect the attempt at honor and
integrity but uh look man we're just at
this point where
you know as I was mentioning with Hassan
you know that segment I I did a response
to like a half an hour long because Ian
pulls up this video the other day where
he it's like Hassan calls out or Tim
pool calls him I was like I was
defending him but the point is the
reason I bring up again if you literally
can't even agree with these people and
they'll come after you or deride you or
insult you then there's no point in
trying anymore and you're not going to
win anything by just giving people who
are crying what they want and in this
regard you take a look at what we have
the AOC video I'll play this one you
look at what happened when Marjory
Taylor green and ghosts are get removed
they're like this is an injustice well
you'll see what happens they literally
cry it's it's just like that Meme where
the where the feminist is throwing
manure over the wall into the internet
yeah and says opinions and then when
people throw it back she goes help
misogyny it's like dude here you go you
guys ready for AOC wait wait wait wait
wait wait always wait hold no no no all
right there we go a general woman is
recognized for one minute thank you now
as also as a fellow New Yorker I think
one of the things that we should talk
about here is also one of the disgusting
legacies after 9 11. she's been
targeting and racism
Americans throughout the United States
of America and this is an extension of
that Legacy consistency there is nothing
consistent with the Republican parties
continued attack except for the racism
and incitement of violence against women
of color in this body I had a member of
the Republicans here we go it's like
playing poetry it is all and the
Republicans rewarded him with one of
them
no she's so she's she's saying that
claiming that anime video Go Star posted
Attack on Titans which showed her as a
gigantic human eating monster being uh
slain by Warriors it was a threat on her
life it was distasteful in my opinion
like I understand the humor behind it
but I'm like I don't know if it's
appropriate you want to you know put
that kind of stuff when people took
memes of the remember the first Kingsman
movie yeah and you remember I'm not even
going to describe it because we're on
YouTube this isn't the third hour maybe
talk about that right right but you
remember the the church scene yeah and
they took like uh Colin Firth just like
kills everybody different different you
know I'm just gonna say political
opponents and attach them to that it's
it's a I I wouldn't post something like
that yeah it's like a will you read that
yeah
she hung out with gosar during the
McCarthy vote and you could see the
pictures of her like oh everyone being
like what is this it's performing very
into him while she's sitting next look
that picture by the way is
right now she knows she's being filmed
and she's campaigning Congress don't
tell
don't tell me marks when you have a
message
about Jewish space lasers and never
happened Marjory Taylor green literally
never said that this is insane she did
say in a Facebook post could lasers have
started these fires and then she made
one reference to funding from a bank and
then the media was like but that bank
was owned by Jewish people therefore
she's talking about Jewish people and
now AOC goes on the floor of the house
and says Jewish space lasers an entire
amount of tropes and also elevated her
to some of the highest committee
assignments in this body this is about
targeting women of color in the in the
United States of America
these people are evil I love the spice I
love it no I love her I'm sorry
yeah right
she hits the table when when she is
performing to manipulate the public to
gain power that to me is what evil is I
mean there's other forms of it don't get
me wrong you know like killing people
and stuff like that but I'm saying this
is malevolent you're saying what she's
doing to the people who are receptive
and like we're laughing about it we're
being we're being jovial but you can hit
the quote tweet button on Twitter right
now I'm sure and you will find people
that are absolutely lapping this up yeah
and they're crying it's like I'm
breaking my heartbreak for this country
thank you AOC thank you for speaking up
these are the same people who believed
her when she implied and you know what
I'm going to bring up she implied that
she was in the capital on January 6 and
that people were coming to kill
her no no no no no she made that story
up in its entirety AOC said in a live
stream that someone was pounding on her
door and she went and hid in the
bathroom and then heard where is Shane
that's right where is she the only
problem first every conservative comes
out and says hey wait a minute she
wasn't in the Capitol building and
everyone in media Huffington Post they
came out and said yes but they're
connected and she was scared that they
made it through the tunnels and I had a
dude from having to post reach out to me
and say hey you're wrong about your
Tweet you need to take it down AOC those
buildings are connected and I responded
with I talked to him I was like oh wow I
didn't realize so I took the Tweet down
and I was like my bad I'll show
correction
I checked the timeline and then I said
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
and I messaged The Huffington Post guy
back and said yes the times frame she
mentioned in this story no one breached
the building until an hour afterwards
and he was like no that that must be a
mistake then he got back to me goes oh
you're actually right yep AOC lied when
that whole story is a lie what really
happened was the police were evacuating
the building if AOC knew and it was an
hour in advance that people were going
to storm the building why didn't you
tell anybody
because either she knew in advance
before anyone breached the building that
they were going to that it was going to
happen
or she's fabricating the story was this
before the okay so when you look at the
timeline and of course you know shout
out to revolver news and rmvd on this
we know that the timing of when Ray Epps
first hit those barricades was almost
precisely coincidental right precisely
coincided with when the pipe bombs were
reported outside of the DNC and the RNC
almost like someone was trying to divert
resources away from that initial and by
the way when I say the initial
barricades these are hundreds of feet
away from the steps of the capital
itself these are all this is what you
would consider part of the lawn right
the National Mall but so when that point
had this knock on the door happened yet
did she know about the pipe bombs or did
this even precede that I don't know if
she knew I don't know what she knew but
the event the reason the some the cop
knocked on her door was that they were
evacuating because of the pipe bombs and
that was a full hour before the capital
was actually breached so AOC had no
reason to believe now what she's doing
is in my opinion using hindsight now
that she knows it happened she's using
that image in people's minds to say how
scared was I when they were coming in
the building right but think about at
the time not a single person knew the
capital would be breached so her story
makes no sense it's a fabrication she is
a liar she is malevolent she is an evil
person sometimes victims of trauma
misremember you know it was literally it
wasn't even 24 hours later she told this
story yeah but she misremember it was
like a few hours later she's like here's
what happened but you know like when a
victim in the park gets jumped by a dude
and she's telling the story of the cop
she's like yeah he was wearing a black
jacket with a they're like do you know
what color his hat was
I think it was 8 p.m and it turns out it
was 10 o'clock and it wasn't 10 o'clock
uh it was a sign out um the sun was out
why was the Sun out at 10 p.m uh I made
the story yeah that's why there are
examples of like victims talking
experiments this is why you can't take
witness testimony as fact well okay AOC
goes on her Instagram and lies like she
always does stop defending but whether
what you mean whether or not she's being
malicious I don't think this is that
that situation I don't think there's
that situation at all I feel like your
yours is closer to like if someone got
jumped and the first thing they did was
go to the media and said this is why
this is why victims don't serve on
juries by the way you you cannot claim
that AOC who was evacuated specifically
because of a bomb threat and that's what
they were told then accidentally
conflated that she thought before the
before the breaching the capital that
the capital had been breached they went
to the tunnels made their way to her
office and then tried breaking into her
room that's insane well they say the
capital I think Capital grounds had been
breached if bombs had been placed but
that's what I'm talking about is when
they're decided they're using the most
expansive definition you could think of
in terms of capital grounds and these
are normally uh public areas this is why
and I was there on January 6 covering it
for oan
that this is why a lot of those people
who are walking around on the grass
didn't think they were doing anything
wrong because that's on any other day
you're just allowed to walk around there
right this is not the steps doors this
wasn't anything like that and so uh
where and re-ups and those guys who were
maskless by the way cutting down
barricades while President Trump was
already was still talking uh those guys
never identified never charged and they
set up the entire thing and many of the
people who walked onto the grounds into
the building were behind where the
barricades were breached so imagine
you're you're a bumbling Goddard with a
bunch of people walking around confused
there's no barricades it's a straight
path up to a door and the police opened
the door and say don't agree with it but
I respect it and you're like I wonder
what this I wonder what that's about
yeah that was that was on one side of
the building on the other side you had
people fighting don't get me wrong those
people should be locked up I remember
those people didn't even know that there
were barricades in the first place I
remember Standing On Top of 101
Constitution Ave and I said that exact
same same thing as it was happening I
said the people because on Constitution
Avenue it's it's it you're all the way
back you have no clue what's going on at
the front so you're just walking up and
it's you're just following the crowd at
that point and one-on-one Constitution
Believe It or Not of course same uh
address where the pen Biden Center is
where they found the classified
documents
um so I'm standing on the roof of that
saying these people are going to walk in
and they're going to get blamed for this
and they're going to have no clue what
transpired me because already cell phone
service was down signal was down you had
no clue you had no way to be able to
find out what had happened and so even
when
they made all these arguments about
Trump's tweets etc etc
how would you know right there was no
way to get access well Twitter or
anything like that we talked to uh like
well they call him Podium guy but it was
a lectern and he said that he had no
idea like his his phone's basically dead
and off and he's walking around confused
like I don't know what's going on any
leaves and all of a sudden he's like all
over the news and they're posting these
pictures of him yeah he had no idea
what's happening and they tried to make
it seem like he was stealing it when he
actually said he moved it like 20 feet
put it down and then did like a you know
yelled something and then walked away
it's like somebody else had moved in he
was moving it back no no he saw it under
the stairs or something and then picked
it up and put in the middle of the room
and then like said like haha like he was
getting a speech and then just walked
away wow oh they made and they made it
seem like he was stealing it from
somewhere yeah I um I pulled up a tweet
from ilhan Omar from earlier today from
I guess this was from about noon today
and it says I'll read it for you it says
uh representation matters we we didn't
come to Congress to be silent we came to
Congress to be a voice for families who
are displaced in refugee camps and those
Seeking Justice around the world so
where were you when MTG was stripped of
all our committees
good question show me one of these
people who are so upset right now who
are screaming who are crying who are are
losing their minds
representation matters we didn't come to
Congress to be silent we came to
Congress to be a voice for families who
are displaced in refugee camps and those
Seeking Justice around the world because
that's what this child's Survivor of War
would have wanted no she came to
Congress to represent her Minnesota
District that's my point first of all
when she says the whole thing we didn't
come to come who's we it's it's illha
who's we didn't come to Congress who are
you talking about
co-conspirators like ilhan it's you
who's talking about her brother maybe
maybe and also you made her husband
you're her husband you make a good point
to him that you know ilhan you didn't go
to Congress to to be a voice for
refugees around the world you went there
to represent the people of Minnesota in
that one small part of Minnesota but not
really I mean she's telling you what she
came to Congress for right
in the world I mean I think she is being
honestly
in her District should now be like oh
interesting interesting that's who you
identify your constituents what you've
just identified though is a trend line
that connects the the Chinese spy story
the spyballoon story to this where we
have to understand that the United
States government or the GAE or whatever
you want to call it the globalist
American Empire is is run throughout
with foreign interests that we've got
foreign interest controlling so much of
our government we've got so much
influence from wealthy foreign
governments whether it be Iran whether
it be China whether it be Qatar that our
whether it be Saudi Arabia et cetera
that are pushing their interests through
these members of Congress because you're
allowed to raise money from anywhere in
the country right you can't you don't
just have to raise money from your own
District so you're representing not only
the people who vote for you but the
people who fund your campaign do like
Saudi princes fund packs that fund camp
that fund politicians probably what do
you think my guess is yes legally a
Saudi Prince is not legally allowed to
give 100 million dollars to a candidate
no American citizen could do that yeah
or even a million bucks what I always
say to the campaign Finance reform like
the people who spurg out on that
um and you find a lot of like a lot of
people on the left really spur guys oh
we need to have like this law and that
law and it's the money's going to get
there the money's going to get there
either way right the money is always
going to find a way to get into these
areas and so this is a fundamental flaw
with the system that if you've got more
money
not always but you know if you're
looking at a race like Congress where
you know how many people can name their
Congressman or remember Congress you
know that you know you're going to say
well I've seen that guy's name a bunch I
guess I'll vote for him or hey this guy
seems crazy because you've got a
well-funded uh smear campaign against
them
and say oh well I can't vote for that
guy because that's not well that's
that's the Jewish space lasers lady I
couldn't vote for her but why Alexandria
ocasio-cortez told me that she's the
Jewish space laser person now
fortunately Margaret Taylor Green's in a
district where I don't think they're
going to be listening to AOC very much
but Lauren bobert isn't and a
well-funded opponent could come in
against Lauren bobert very easily you
saw this almost happen right where I
don't think people realized how close
she came something like 500 votes yeah
and so this is always going to be a
problem with the American model of
government because of the representative
the House of Representatives can be
bought off or bribed by corporate people
that want to give their laws so the
representatives passed their laws into
the Senate if there were no
Representatives if this was all like
direct representation where you gotta
you'd have to bribe 700 000 of us if you
want our district to vote a certain way
not going to happen not not likely not
as likely as one person uh they would
still pay lawyers to pass laws into the
Senate so it's either like the richest
people are always going to dominate
politics or the most intelligent and
able to write laws will could possibly I
could see like a well-educated populace
could
take become more valuable than the
monetary system but the webs is the
people that are rich will buy the
intelligent people off the lawyers and
stuff and they'll find that smartest
lawyers to write the best laws for them
and then it becomes like a bidding war I
I
there's a reason that when we talk about
Davos so Davos just ended and this is
sort of the meeting of the globalist
American Empire where they where they
sit and sort of cackle around about what
they're going to be doing and there's an
interesting take on that because I think
people realize that it's it's a it's
tough to put a specific word to it but
we understand that when you see the AOC
performative art and the theater from
Rashida Talib we realize that these
aren't the actual people that are making
the decisions these aren't the people
that are actually ruling over us these
aren't the people that are setting the
agenda and you're seeing that more and
more even in the Biden Administration as
they're removing long-time allies and uh
confidants and advisors like Ron Clane
and then getting in people like Jeff
zenz who is a Bain Capital uniparty guy
the same way that he's sort of like you
know the Democrat side of Bane the way
that Romney was the Republican side of
vain but they're really the same company
right it's a great it's actually a
perfect example for us to understand
this that this is how the unit party
works so they're able to get their
people in
and even the bite Administration itself
nobody nobody sits there and talks about
the incredible Biden campaign and the
Mastery of the uh you know this who was
Biden's campaign manager
Obama's campaign managers went on to
have some of the most successful media
careers they run some of the most
successful podcasts on the left right
now with the Biden campaign who did they
launch there's nothing there's
absolutely because people understand
that that was predominantly the power
structure deciding to pluck him up and
bring him in as president and we call
this the globalist American they they
said stay alive Joe Biden all we need is
your corporeal form that's right that
was it that was a news article what was
it the Atlantic they wrote there's
something like that yeah stay alive Joe
Biden let me see if I can find this but
I think I think what we're seeing now
though and this is why to go back to 101
Constitution Atlantic there you go the
Atlantic same thing right and what what
date did that come out this is uh
March 24th 2020. Democrats he wasn't
even Democrats little from the front
runner Beyond his corporeal presence
that's great they were right and that's
pretty much all right you will not have
a president you will have a a a
figurehead in an old retiree a vessel
yeah and that's you need someone to sit
in the chair but he's not going to
really do it but I think I think what
we're seeing right now with the
classified documents coming out with
Hunter Biden very stupidly
um admitting that the laptop was his oh
that was amazing threatening to fire
lawsuit file lawsuits against those of
us that were that were spreading it in
20 which please do by the way please sue
me Hunter Biden I'd I'd be more than
happy to get Discovery in a lawsuit with
Hunter Biden so please Hunter Biden have
your lawyers contact my lawyers Sumi sue
me right now I figured out uh Biden's
campaign manager was Greg Schultz who's
that what's he up to now you see what I
mean it takes exactly my point it's kind
of the same way that like it when we
were talking about the current thing
earlier that during in if you weren't
old enough to remember the sort of post
911 era we were you know suddenly we
became uh experts in the Middle East and
you know you had to know you know who's
the best prime minister for Afghanistan
is it a shrief ghani or is it is it
Karzai uh who should be the next leader
of Iraq and we must topple Saddam
Hussein because Saddam Hussein is the
you know the greatest threat to world uh
world peace right now the same way
you've got people talking about toppling
Iran you know tomorrow but here we are a
couple what two decades later and nobody
talks about Iraq anymore we know Taliban
the Taliban retook Afghanistan nobody
even mentions them because you're not
told to mention them I thought that the
other day I was like all these people
that are like hey we want Russians out
of Ukraine it is not right for a country
to invade a smaller foreign country
where were they when they were talking
about pulling our troops out of Iraq
like when the America we're still
invading Iraq Libya at least we still
have troops here in Syria right now so
get them out get them out speak up about
it that that's why I hate to bring it up
again but when when Hassan did his
response to me and he's like the
military industrial complex is bad but
we should be in Ukraine it's like what
do you think that is what do you think
all of this has always been but that's
an excellent point Ian that all these
people are like Russia what did Kamala
Harris say Russia as a big country and
they invaded a little country and that's
why it's bad it's like oh well the
United States is a big country and we
invaded a couple little countries was
that bad I will actually give Kamala
Harris credit on that because for a
little bit because I try to I try to
find things that I like about the other
side and and it makes it harder that way
right um You have to be easy to just rip
on them but she actually does have a
point that you don't really hear that
when people are talking about the
Strategic military calculus of we're
going to send more tanks well okay but
how many tanks well like 15. okay well
how many tanks does Russia have they
have 1200 right so what are your 50 what
are 15 and zelinski says this all the
time he said it on in an interview with
Trey angst at Fox News today that he
said well you're going to send 15 tanks
they have thousands of Tanks what
difference is this really going to make
to us are you going to send f-16s but
then if you send f-16s who's going to
fly them how are you going to train
someone what are the logistics for that
was the maintenance for that and then
keep in mind they say okay we'll build a
maintenance facility yeah we'll guess
what the next cruise missile is going to
fly into right you don't take out all
the tanks just take out the maintenance
facility we've been talking about the
complex the collapse of complex systems
well when you're in Wartime you just
amplify that by about a hundred imagine
you know you can't find the right lug
nut because oh wait uh American tanks
use the conventional system but European
tanks use the metric system right so
you're where you're going to find the
right pieces for a leopard that fit in
Abrams etc etc all of these issues that
come into play I want to pull up the uh
under Biden story this is an amazing
story right here CNN politics Hunter
Biden calls for criminal probe and
aggressive new legal strategy this is my
favorite this is my favorite thing
favorite anything here right they say uh
the allegations made in letters to the
Delaware attorney general uh the Justice
Department's National Security division
in the IRS marked the first time
President Joe Biden's son and his legal
team have publicly acknowledged that it
was his personal data purported to be
found on a laptop left at a Delaware
repair shop let me just come out and say
hunter Biden thinking he's going on the
legal offensive says he wants a criminal
probe into the laptop
and even CNN was like wow he admitted it
was his now here's the best part they
came out I don't know if I actually have
here we go yeah from Jackie Heinrich
attorney for Hunter Biden tells me
letters requesting investigation into
the laptop repair store owner Julian and
others are not acknowledgment the laptop
is in fact Hunters which makes no sense
because if it's not his then he's not
the victim
if it's not designed it's not the victim
so so so then he's got by the way he's
not a victim anyway because it's Salvage
law
well I guess the argument he's trying to
make is and they've long made this is
that maybe the laptop was uh someone
hacked his data put it on a laptop and
then dropped it off there to to trick
everyone at this point conspiracy at
this point that laptop that hard drive
that we were going through in October of
2020 when Steve Bannon handed me and
Rahim a copy of that thing and said have
at it boys that uh not a single person
has been able to come through and find
anything that was changed that was
altered that was added that was edited
not once and by the way this isn't just
like a copy of files it's an actual
clone of his laptop from that period of
time well it was his actual laptop yeah
and then copies of the hard drive were
made that's right so I mean you're when
I when you you actually need a um you
need a Mac OS from that time frame in
order to even boot the thing yeah that's
how much of a clone it is did he have
any games on that laptop or if you don't
have to if you're not allowed to answer
then you don't have to answer that's not
something
well the crazy thing is uh is that
there's so much information still on the
laptop that's not been released and it's
because people don't know what to look
for
so when a story comes out like the
classified documents right then people
go let's search for this information and
see if we can find anything oh hey wow
there's emails so well it's also like
you you get more information and then
because there's a lot of it because it's
it's you know you're getting chains of
emails but you don't always get the star
at the end Etc or you see names and some
of these people aren't necessarily
mentioned in in press so you're not sure
exactly who it is and you have the
ability to take lead on it but again
it's it's just someone's personal laptop
so there's thousands and thousands of
emails on it so what uh what happens is
exactly what you just said that
something happens in the real world and
then it gives you new context to go back
and look at the exact same thing that
you had seen a million times before but
then realize what it is there's a ton of
emails on the laptop and if you don't
know what you're looking for you're
seeing static like on a TV but if
someone points out hey Hunter Biden
lived at this house and they were
classified documents here someone says
okay let me search the database and see
if these keywords come up whoa they did
you don't even know what to look for
until you know what to look for you know
what I mean what so so they're not
calling for a lawsuit though they want
he wants a criminal probe so are they
gonna they're gonna send the doj after
you Jack
greater men than you have tried yeah
what's the pro ball what's a criminal
pro ball about what would that entail
and what's the purpose no like I guess
they're arguing maybe like Computer
Fraud and Abuse Act or something
December like they're seeing if there's
enough there
well by the way and I'm just gonna say
publicly that what IO whenever we booted
this thing up there was something I said
from day one I said do not connect this
thing to the internet don't connect it
not one second because I don't and I
don't even know but if his Apple ID is
associated with that thing then if you
connect this to the internet which I've
never done then if it starts syncing
let's say his Apple ID hasn't changed it
starts syncing now you're in violation
because now you're downloading new
information that was not left with
Johnny MacIsaac at that store and by the
way chatted with lawyers etc etc about
all of this uh extensively and and that
was sort of the the point was that
anything that was left the store was
left yeah there's so many copies of this
laptop floating around now it's crazy
yeah I hear from like random people
they're like oh yeah our news team's
doing and I'm like wow much like to be
Hunter
you know look uh don't get cracked out
don't your laptop yeah don't don't smoke
crack and leave your laptop lying or
which I I love that story that um if you
remember early on there were a bunch of
like you know journalists saying well
that story of that and Rudy giuliani's
never made any sense of me you never
heard of a crackhead losing something
right
story I could think of I wouldn't be
surprised if he's also Rich he didn't
care about the laptop so when it broke
he probably just was like
you know I'm not gonna go and pick it up
I don't know I got a lot of things to do
forgets about it and someone's like you
ever go get your laptop back I don't
know what I don't know what the data on
my new computer one of the big angles
that I've I've always he could have just
forgotten too and thought he lost it
looking around for his laptop the next
day what can I do with that thing
um and then just goes and buys a new one
because he thinks he lost it something
that I do want to bring up though
because we've been talking about the
potential for foreign influence we've
been talking about how our country has
owned all of the information that we
have on that laptop all of the the data
all of the voicemails the talks of the
Chinese Communist Party the deals with
barisma the Ukrainian energy firm who
just had their uh their former owner the
money guy behind it the oligarch Igor
kalamoiski was raided this week by the
government of Ukraine they're clean
they're cleaning up Loose Ends over
there
that guy had been a huge backer of
zielinski by the way as well in his TV
show and his campaign he was just rated
so you know GA is is is tying up blue
sense but the
when I think of this and I compare it to
sort of like a dossier that we would see
in the IC that this isn't a dossier or
if it is a dossier this is the dossier
that Hunter Biden had on himself right
this isn't something that an
intelligence uh organization would put
together so imagine what
Eastern European intelligence Services
have on Hunter Biden from what he was
doing there that even he didn't save
imagine what the Chinese Communist Party
the ministry and security second Bureau
has on this guy because this is the
stuff that he wasn't filming himself
saving himself recording himself what
was the stuff that was too hot for
Hunter Biden to even put out there right
so that's what they have on him and I
think I think at this point what we're
really seeing and it's it's you know
it's an interesting
story to get into but it's it's the
power of the Biden family is over
um they're pretty much dying they're
they're spent and they're gonna take
they're going to take old man by no
banjo and they're gonna hold them by the
liver spot at hand they're going to give
them a glass of warm milk and maybe some
you know mashed peas and Brussels
sprouts and they're going to walk them
out the front door and then get Sprouts
are a little too hard for old you know
we'll steam brussels sprouts yeah my mom
used to see them they're very Sprouts
are good actually yeah
then they're going to walk them out of
the White House he's done they'll send
them off to Rehoboth the son of a woman
whatever you know I hope it's nice
um and they are going to prepare and
then Kamala just forget about that um
not even what we're talking about and
they're going to pave the way for Mr
hair gel Hitler himself Gavin Newsom
hair gel Hitler how would you rate him
on a scale of one to a hundred just
quality wise and what 100 is good or bad
100 is the best who's excited about him
one like the best really you think he's
the worst well I think
I think the regime the GAE wants a new
Once knew fresh blood and so what's
interesting though is for Gavin Newsom
is that his biggest problem is going to
be getting through the Democrat Southern
primaries because he doesn't have any
put it this way he doesn't have any
intersectional Pokemon points
um he's a straight white male who's
married to a straight white female and
they have have white children so there's
no intersectional Pokemon point so he is
Hitler basically right so I mean
obviously Hitler so hair gel Hitler on
the other hand he's got to think of
something to appeal to those voters in
the Democrat primaries in Georgia and
South Carolina and what's California
talking about right now what's the
California Council that he's just
instituted reparations yeah that's
exactly so he's going to campaign and
he's going to use this as a national
platform to say I was the first state in
the nation to provide for there's
already some cities in like San
Francisco and others that's bribery he's
got yes it is what
this is going to be his National
platform right and it'll benefit him
that so many people fled California they
didn't leave their uh favoritism for him
behind they just moved to Southern
States I think we should talk about the
uh the historical racism of the Japanese
internment camps right and how that
affected all uh people from from the
Asian diaspora and their and their
relatives and how uh they're deserving
of reparations too that's right yeah
that's right so here's I would like this
is for a hundred thousand dollars this
is the take on on reparations that and
and it's it's not even to get into the
question but if you have if you have the
US government handing out 25 000 checks
to one group of people and nobody else
you're gonna tear this country apart at
the seams yeah this is tear this country
apart and this is what I talk about the
problem with this uh leftist racist
psycho psychotic ideology that you have
you have a neighborhood on the south
side of Chicago that is predominantly
black but it's only like 90 percent and
then you have Latinos and white people
and it's lower income and then the
government comes in and gives out checks
to only the black people yep like that
that's gonna cause a lot of problems
yeah like it's gonna cause crazy like I
mean the gangs are going to go off for
one but people are going to get pissed
off well and then first thing the gangs
are going to do is go run to everyone
who got that check and go start
collecting checks that's right I mean
you're gonna you're gonna see in the
taxes are due I lived through and by the
way I appreciate you the shout out the
other day on on when I I'd written that
story about my home oh yeah man losing
my my right I did a whole thing about it
we had a great we had a great town and
the house I was born in was something
like 84 years old by the time I uh was
there was the house my father grew up in
and that was what you did and everybody
knew everybody the kids I played with
were the children of the kids that my
dad played with when he was a kid and on
the same block on the same town uh
there's about you know eight miles out
of Philadelphia just just a regular
normal Northeast you know kind of
quasi-industrial town and that picture
that's on the article is is my house
that from when we left it or you know
kind of a little before we left to where
it is today and it's just it's it's you
know it's it's
bad what happened Pizza Hut nationalism
man what happened it's a crime just just
it's all crime it's all crime
um it became a sanctuary City for uh for
Mexican IDs when that was a big thing in
like 2002 the hospital shut down uh the
hospital I was born in was was uh
destroyed and raised to the ground now
because the company that bought it and
realized that they'd never make any
money there so they shut down the
hospital the homicide rate has gone up
like crazy uh rapes violent crime et
cetera Etc it's just just spiraled into
this this CD uh Town that's that's you
you can go back and you have these great
I have these great memories of growing
up there but then even
you know my brother and I were sort of
chatting it about it after I wrote this
thing that this is Norristown
Pennsylvania
um that if you you know we we remember
right remember the dog fights that were
going on in the alley when we were
trying to learn how to ride bikes and
the drug dealer is getting arrested
every week but then they'd be back every
week and nothing ever seen having the
cops there all the time
um my mom used to let us walk to the
library which was a couple of blocks
down but then uh homeless people kept
stabbing each other there wow so we
weren't allowed to do that anymore and
uh I remember my brother told me a story
I wasn't there but he said he remembers
looking out the window one day and they
were just looking across the street
these two guys just like just just
beating each other up like right there
on the street in like the middle of the
day kind of stuff and this was going on
and on you couldn't have a bike or you
might just kept getting stolen and it
just kept getting worse and worse and
worse and finally I finally got us out
and the house is beautiful house is
absolutely gorgeous three stories
um you know my mom said that if we if we
could have taken it with us us we would
have because it was so nice to grow home
but it's it's that that story isn't
unique to me and I'm not special for
having lived it but it you have this
happen to communities all across the
entire country and I think I think we
misuse the word Community you know we
say you know we say like we talk about
it at like a racial group or an ethnic
group or a gender group now or a trans
Community but but a community a real
Community is people that have known each
other that have bonds of familiarity for
that go back Generations they used to go
to church together yeah somebody super
chatted uh asking if I knew that they
paid reparations to Japanese internment
camp uh families I knew that absolutely
that's why I said Asian diaspora Asian
diet he was making a point my point is
that um when it comes to the reparations
in places like California how do you
know how are you going to go through and
make sure every single person is a
descendant of of someone who is enslaved
and then are you really going to follow
through because that means there will be
many white people who will Trace lineage
back to you know a great great
grandmother or father who was black and
then are they entitled to you know to
this so my grandmother is high
cheekbones so if the natives are
involved well who's who's that uh who's
that famous actor
um he's he's he what's his name Mel
Brooks what I just know the guy from
prison break we're just watching you
know what I'm talking about the other
day the guy he's the guy from prison
break he's also Captain Cold in the uh
The Flash show I forgot his name but um
he's I think he's like one eighth black
but he just looks like a white guy yeah
like is he gonna get Wentworth Miller
there you go there you go yeah he does
good work I like uh I like stuff he's
done he's Captain Cold I dig that stuff
I like DC or he's only got one eighth no
but like no does he get one eighth of
the check no I get it but like what's
gonna happen when like there's a line
full of people walking up to get their
checks and there's a bunch of white
people that are getting the checks and
they're like wait what's going on it's
like whoa then there's gonna be also a
bunch of black people who are like
Nigerian immigrants or Haitians exactly
what I'm saying San Francisco is has
this reparations committee what do you
mean like Kamala Harris and Barack Obama
exactly they should get a check man they
were they were affected but San
Francisco has their operations committee
and they put forth this idea like you'll
give uh it's five million dollars for
each black resident of San Francisco and
you have to have either prove that your
uh connected to a you're the tenant of a
slave or that you emigrated to San
Francisco during a certain time period
and then also the California was never a
slave state yeah right California was a
free state that's right the whole time
admit it as a free state except for the
Chinese well yeah right yes well as I'm
saying by Asian diaspora you know I and
and the reason I say that is because
people couldn't tell the difference back
then you know my family was oppressed by
the the white supremacy yep patriarchy
systems you got to give me money yeah
where's my money give me that I agree I
don't think it's I don't think it's
possible to solve technically and I also
don't think that throwing money at
people is the way to help them
necessarily I mean a little bit if you
have zero you know you give them a
thousand having a thousand is a lot
different than having zero it's a big
difference from going to one thousand to
two thousand like once you get out of
zero that's something but on top of that
like where what are we repairing but Ian
you tell me you're assuming that the
people pushing this stuff actually care
about solving a problem I think they're
trying to bribe constituations
that's not a solution I'm okay I'd like
to say that they say no if you teach a
man to fish you know you feed them for a
day I'm sorry if you give a metaphase if
you feed him for a day teach your
manifest your feeding for the rest of
your life and then they also people say
you got to pick yourself up by your
bootstraps picking yourself up by your
bootstraps requires you have boots yes
and teaching someone to fish if they're
really going to feed themselves for the
rest of their lives they need a fishing
pole so there's gotta there's somewhere
that's not it's you know well I don't
know about cooking a fishing pole they
need a fishing but right you can't be
like you saw your fish good luck finding
a fishing pole because they're gonna be
like yo I can't fish unless I have one
of those things you can Spearfish I
guess make one out of a stick and then
pick yourself up by your bootstraps you
gotta have boots to do that so my
attitude is kind of like can we provide
the the means for self-sufficiency but
then require self-sufficiency like we're
not going to feed you tomorrow we're
going to tell you how you do it and then
it's up to you like we're gonna we're
gonna give you the tools you need to do
it it seems like the only sustainable
way if I was playing a game and that was
one of my options that would be the only
feasible Way Forward would be to pray
that people would figure out how to
sustain themselves if you give them a
little bit once that's the only way I
mean this was the same argument that was
made for the general amnesty in 1982 6
when Reagan went for it that you know
we're going to deal with this once a
little bit and then it'll go away that
we're just going to give a little bit of
amnesty and then we'll never have an
illegal immigration problem again that
was Ronald Reagan that was 1986.
California has never been read again and
he also is the gun control guy and no
fault divorce guy so anyway but let's uh
let's do a hard segue and jump to the
story because we got to do it this is
from The Daily Mail man we really do
like them don't we two women who denied
being trafficked by Andrew Tate and his
brother and insist they worked for him
willingly our victims and have been
brainwashed Romanian judge rules so uh I
guess it's believe all women unless
those women go against The Narrative of
the men you're trying to imprison I'm
actually struggling to follow the
grammar of this headline they
two women came out and said yo it's not
true we're not victims and the judge
went we were here now you're brainwashed
we were not coerced we were here happily
and he's like no you don't understand
you were coerced you you were being I
don't know okay now this is a matrix
attack I'm sorry at this point yeah for
real because and by the way there are
they are they people are like are they
is it a major attack against Andrew Tate
or did he really do these things and I'm
like man you know honestly I don't know
now that a judge was like these two
witnesses who support Andrew Tate yeah
they're actually victims and we're
hearing about my statements here's my
confusion is have the Tate Brothers been
charged no so what is the ruling what
does the ruling pertain to this is why
I'm like at this point it's a matrix
attack because I'm I'm off by the way
and I've said this for everybody I've
said this for Epstein I've said this for
um but I don't know if you guys saw that
that story The ABC producer the guy who
they thought was missing and then it
turned out that he was apparently like
messaging kids on Snapchat asking for
porn all sorts of crazy stuff
um that show me the evidence right show
me the evidence and let's have a fair
trial when it was Kyle Rittenhouse I
said you showed me the evidence when it
was Alec Baldwin I said show me the
evidence and you know he had a live
bullet in his gun he had live Ham on his
gun belt of course he had live out on
his gun belt the whole thing was live
and of course he was using the hammer
and of course he was playing around with
the trigger I think I think he murdered
I think he put the bull in it so did you
actually read the an over jumping
stories but did you actually read the um
the probable cause uh summary no so
from my reading of it it didn't seem as
though the investigation turned up
actual footage of the shooting it said
in their investigation they were able to
uncover evidence of filming immediately
prior to the shooting with his finger on
the chair with his finger on the trigger
and he's fiddling with the with the
hammer which of course decreases the
pressure that it would require for a
long pull trigger Etc et cetera but
it didn't say that they had actual
footage of because if they had they
would just say it yeah right so it
didn't I don't think that they've
actually turned up footage of the
shooting I just think just to wrap that
one up and go back to the Andrew Tate
stuff real quick it's like he shot a
woman pulled a gun pulled the hammer
back pulled the trigger and everyone's
like oh it was an accident where'd the
live bullet come from he had them on his
belt like Alec Baldwin was in possession
of a gun right possession of live
ammunition pointed at a woman he was
having arguments with and shot her like
a staffer a staffer okay anyway the
Andrew Tate thing which by the way but
Tim what you're doing right now is
you're analyzing the evidence because
the evidence has been presented to us
yes and so now you can conclude a
illegal analysis based on the severity
the weight The credibility of that
evidence what we have here we have no
charges we have we have some statements
and apparently the judge is telling the
people who made the statements that
they're not allowed to make those these
are these are witnesses supporting the
Tate Brothers being told they did not
recognize that they were being enslaved
so when this happened and the question
was people are like is the machine
coming after him or did he do this and a
lot of people were like well you know
the things the things he said I'm like
at this point when you get Witnesses who
are like we're here to speak in in
support of this man and the judge goes
nah you're brainwashed get out all right
let's read that the they're a clinical
psychologist did an assessment
and then it was described as
extrajudicial evidence but judges of the
Bucharest court of appeal did take the
report into consideration over
yesterday's decision
this is crazy dude so they found some
clinical psychologists they've been
charged with any crimes no crimes
because of that assessment which which
by the way may also mean that if they're
going to take this rule so let's say
they are charged right let's say they
are charged and they go to court et
cetera et cetera does that mean that
these two women can now not appear as
Witnesses because they've already been
ruled against
I don't know I don't know I don't know
this would be that this would be
excluded from them so it looks like they
were appealing the the actual
um because in Romania they have this
thing where you can be held while you're
under investigation as opposed to before
you recharged and then they I think it
was 30 days and they extended another 30
days
which is kind of it's like 120 now right
right so point being is they're they're
trying to fight that initial detention I
think they lost that ruling already and
but I think that's the ruling that
they're talking about yeah that so they
they did away with it my question is
though does that create a a pretext does
that create a situation where if they
want to come in and appear as witnesses
to say excuse me we're not victims we're
Witnesses
um that they're already going to say no
probably that's what it seems like
that's literally what they're doing
they're saying that because the women
were lover boy traffic like they thought
they were in love or potentially going
to marry these guys that they can't
understand that they are actually being
recruited you know women have no agency
I guess don't I know it yeah they can't
make decisions for themselves apparently
so what you're saying is repeal the 19th
Amendment I'm gonna go that far no I
mean I'm just saying I mean isn't that
the obvious well so the in Romania
perhaps can women vote the underlying
the other line is exactly what you just
said though because the under in this
clinical psychologist and again we're
responding to what the court has ruled
we are not saying these things but the
logical conclusion of what you're saying
is that clearly that women have no
agency because men lie to them and so
women are not responsible for their
actions and if women are not responsible
for their actions and their decisions
then why should we put women in a
position where they they're making the
most important decisions uh life and
death War and Peace trade uh that we
should we should take this away from
them because these these evil men with
by the way Ian of course with these
Financial campaigns these uh well-funded
campaigns that are used against these
poor women that they're just being
victimized over and over and over and
that's why that's why we should take
this pressure the burden take a look at
this famous meme image It's a poster it
says Jake was drunk Josie was drunk Jake
and Josie hooked up Josie could not
consent the next day Jake was charged
with rape a woman who was intoxicated
cannot give her legal consent for sex so
proceeding under these circumstances of
crime it only takes a simple day to ruin
your life think about it be responsible
I can't read the bottom the woman has no
agency and is no not responsible for for
raping no doesn't say who who made it
you can't really see something
University yeah some University yeah
always I'm really concerned about this
consent conversation because I
understand if someone is being
trafficked in some way or like put
through some hell and they are
brainwashed into thinking that
everything's fine and then they come out
and they tell everyone hey everything's
totally fine and you're like okay I can
see that situation what do they call
that uh Stockholm syndrome where the
victim actually thinks that the the
captor is a good guy you know I get that
but at the same time if someone consents
to something no matter what you can't if
you sign a contract under duress the
contract doesn't it's not a real
contract so I understand that when you
but
when I was back in Hollywood I was being
trafficked so take them all down this is
different like these women are trying to
say we are not under duress like how do
you prove that you're not under duress
if the court says you are right like
like if if you were accused of a crime
and then you bring two witnesses who say
we've worked with them they're good guys
we love and respect them and the judge
goes you're brainwashed dismissed you're
gonna stay in jail that's what I'm
talking about now look perhaps the
mistake the Tate brothers made was
setting up a base of operations in
Romania of all places and I don't know
why they chose that place
because I mean it's not like Eastern
Europe is known for like being
anti-corrupt right it's like you take a
look at what's going on in Ukraine right
now it bit him back he said that's the
reason he was there is because you could
get away with a lot of things but they
didn't think this would actually happen
you know of course it will yeah don't
exactly the thing about the US
I was talking to
um
well I'll keep the story relatively
private I don't know if it's public
story but they they do this race I
forgot what's called they Race Across
Russia and because there's so much
corruption you can go 120 miles an hour
you get pulled over you just hand cash
to the cop and you're free to go like
you you can't do that in the United
States which but by the way that's most
countries in the world right yeah not in
the United States though yeah we talk
about a political corruption but let's
be honest like cops tend to not be
corrupt I mean we have corrupt cops we
have abusive cops but I guarantee you if
you get pulled over and say to the cop
you're gonna offer my bribe he's gonna
back out of the car you're under arrest
yeah no that's just our politicians
right politicians are different they get
bribery from the lobbyists but a cop is
going to lock you up and be like I'm not
going down for what you just did I'm
taking the note you offered me a bribe
you're under arrest I think people in
general don't it's it's a strange
dichotomy where we believe that we're
relatively uh to to places like South
Africa for example hey American police
are are far more
um
far less corrupt I should say that
relatively than there or anywhere in in
some of these Eastern European
post-soviet countries but at the same
time our politicians are far far far
more corrupt than the politicians of
almost any other country
um we don't talk about it that way for
some reason but the amount of money that
and even you would just you just
explained it very well how it happens
that the amount of money that's able to
find their way into their pockets
whether I mean there's a reason that
like Gavin Newsom right go look at the
uh you know the maglev project the
high-speed rail of California that never
existed despite spending tens of
billions of dollars which of course was
washed back into his campaigns which was
washed back into his support uh that
went to all these developers and
consultants and environmental impact
surveys etc etc that the whole thing was
a money wash the same way that Libya and
Afghanistan the current situation these
are these are money washes by and large
and George Orwell wrote this when
talking about Warfare but you could talk
about it with a lot of these government
corrupt agencies that the the point of
the war is not so that it should be one
the point of the war is that it should
be continuous
yeah yeah
money making machine I guess I'm deeply
concerned about this Andrew Tate thing
at this point this is really this is
really starting to bother me because
because these girls were very plain that
they they weren't being roughed up by
them that he wasn't that they weren't
being trafficked by them they said it
specifically said it out loud to the
judge and it was dismissed like this is
it they've made videos about it where
they're like this is not true they're
calling us victims we're not victims and
they're like yeah they're just
brainwashed I mean show me the you know
where's the evidence like
the passport was taken and it was put in
the safe and they were told that they
couldn't get the passport back and so
they were stuck in the country until
they worked off their their debt lay
that out for me right if that's what
happened show it to me show me the
evidence and I've always said this name
the names show me the evidence let's
have it all out I'm perfectly happy with
looking into any of those situations but
for some reason in this case you don't
seem to get that and by the way and you
know if that ends up being what it is
then okay so be right right totally but
show me that yes exactly yeah the
process is concerning because I think
they're treating the process as the
punishment kafka's book
um the trial in the original in the
original German the title is dear
process and the main character I can't
think of the name of taught me how but
the main character is he's charged at
the beginning he's brought into and this
is the in the 1920s and this is like
Weimar Germany he was writing that so
he's charged
he's brought in uh to jail he's told
that he's going to okay this is your
lawyer these are the different uh
arguments that you can make this is what
you could do at the trial he goes to
trial et cetera et cetera the very the
last scene of the whole thing he's being
drug away to his own execution but never
once in the book do they actually say
what he was charged for right exactly
wow dear process well we're gonna go to
Super Chat so if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends become a member over
at timcast.com to check out our members
only uncensored show which goes up at
about 11 p.m always good not so family
friendly fun so uh definitely could use
your support smash that like button
let's read what y'all got to say in the
super chats all right
gross John says shout out to pop culture
crisis search pop culture crisis
greatest hits on YouTube if you want to
see PCC parody and out of context
including Scary Mary robot Mary Mary
Saves the World Ian in smurfland and
Hannah Claire's sweet dance moves oh my
gosh I hate that video it's hilarious
but like wow your dads are good yeah
they've gotten like a serious meme
culture on pop culture crisis or at
least meme creators that support them
which is super cool it's a great show
Ryan Hunter says can I get a happy
birthday today for my great grandmother
Eleanor who is 100 nice everything from
the Great Depression to now in one
person's life amazing now happy birthday
Eleanor yeah it's awesome there you go
nice job
OMG puppy says haha balloons China and
Rush have satellites in fact guess who
launched the world's first satellite it
was Russia it was Sputnik right that was
the the first Sputnik also the first uh
the first
when I say manned but the first uh
satellite with living creature right the
monkey the dog oh they said a dog
from the from the streets of Moscow
right you know the urban legend that uh
Yuri gagarin's not the first man in
space Oh wait who do they say it was I
don't know the name but they think that
the Soviets launched a man in space and
he got lost oh right no I have heard
this and so they never said anything so
they said hey
shout out to Leica the first dog in
space did he make it back no no no no no
definitely not where did it go
uh to Doggy heaven but I mean like did
the ship just go and disappear in space
no no we came back
it fell back burned on the impact yeah
did not make it back they trained the
dog to press buttons and stuff oh yeah
of course yeah crazy yeah there was a
whole program uh physical conditioning
had to give up cigarettes
all right we got this uh we got this one
from Matthew recamp he says I gotta push
back on your take on Omar first she's
not being kicked from all committees
like MTG just the Foreign Affairs
committee second her defense for making
any submit because she didn't know
tropes that anyone could tell about she
claimed she didn't know there were
antisemitic tropes about Jews and money
and everybody's just like oh come on
dude what uh yeah no no way Matt Gates
when he was on said he would like to
come back with El Han Omar at some point
really good or AOC yeah he said AOC he
said Johan Omar it might to me and I
thought that would be a great absolutely
because they're We're Young I don't I
don't I don't think I don't know AOC
maybe yeah I mean I don't agree with the
politics but that's that's the point but
that's why she was willing that's a
tough question because because IL and
Omar like the show that we would have
with ilhan Omar would be
I mean she's involved in a lot of shady
stuff right yeah the the the guy she was
cheating on the wife and all that stuff
the weird brother stuff that's why I'm
like I don't think she'd come on this
show because we're gonna be like let's
talk about these social media posts yeah
sure remember those and they took them
down but they're archived and it was
Star Tribune in Minnesota that wrote
they they actually said this that her
husband may he may be her brother yeah
and then I I read that and I went whoa
they actually said that and then Media
Matters claimed I said it I'm like hey
this is star tribute this is like a
prominent newspaper I don't know if
she's gonna want to come on the show
she's there people are going to be like
do not go on that show AOC maybe but AOC
like if if AOC were to come on the show
I would at tremendous respect for her
bravery in the face of me calling her a
liar who fabricated a fake Capital
January 6th story yeah yeah would you
ask her about it of course yeah yeah no
freebies you would have them on the show
it's just that they wouldn't accept
basically yeah I don't know yeah the
shows would be nuts if they were willing
if they were willing yeah it's not it's
not this podcast issue it's them right
it always is like the the the issue is
on the left they live in this
brainwashed cult world for the most part
not every single one many people just
don't really pay attention but it's like
the worst things you could say about
Matt Gates hey that turned out to be
fake it was blackmail on his family this
crazy story they ran about him and then
it was like oh it was blackmail and the
guy's getting arrested for it now so
it's like okay well I don't need to talk
to him about it that seems nonsensical
but like alien Omars we like having it'd
be like having Donald Trump up up and
asking about the steel dossier yeah it's
just not real you know yeah well let's
let's read some more we've got Raymond g
Stanley Jr says Tim I got the new lgbtq
Sims update I'm a trans woman athlete
conquering female sports but I'm having
to restart the game so I keep dying
suddenly
well I heard about the new inclusive
Sims update yeah Alessio Damonte says
money for bucko thank you very much oh
my God it was expensive devoc says shout
out to bocus Mr bocus I hope this uh
this treatment works yeah it looks good
I'll let him know how often do you take
him back every two weeks for how long uh
well there's three doses lined up and
then I think it might just continue on I
don't know I think we just keep doing it
yeah and then if this works we had the
prognosis from the vet from I think
three different vets he's not gonna make
it his kidneys are declining when we
brought him in the first time there like
at stage three kidney failure and then
it moved to like stage four and they're
like he's not gonna make it so now we're
getting him this treatment and if he
does they gotta like publish something
about yeah put his data in something
yeah we're taking data as we go like
with this pieces and the real expensive
part was the actual harvesting it's a
one-time thing was like five grand the
rest of it's you know nickels and
diamonds about a thousand dollars is the
rest of it after that so if you are
considering a treatment like that you
just know that going on it's a one-time
big pain I just don't think most people
can afford to yeah we got to make this a
cheaper technology yeah that's a big
part of my there's no place in uh pet
cloning is is starting to come online
do you know that company clone Aid we
were looking on that last night I would
never do all sorts of stuff I wouldn't
do it nah not interested
clone it is a human clothing what am I
like a family member like if you if you
you know you're you know you got a dog
from somewhere and then oh hey this is
uh you know like the nephew or whatever
the other thing would be fun do you
think do you think clones have souls
above my pay grade
I don't know I feel like if you cloned
your pet you'd get like a soulless you
know kind of thing they got Souls like
it's hard it's like I don't think people
assume you mean clones of people well
like yeah but if you cloned your pet it
doesn't mean it would be exactly the
same every way right like your pet
develops personality right I don't know
it'd be a different animal sometimes
yeah
and wouldn't that be sad if you're like
you love your pet and then it's just
like yeah that Cemetery though that's
one of those movies where and just like
the new the new Halloween that like once
you have kids you just can't watch stuff
like that anymore that's why that's true
right because you just psychologically
and biologically and spiritually you
can't help but think what if that were
my kid yeah yeah and it it just just
even even the thought of it just
absolutely drives me I don't watch
horror movies anymore I just real life I
go on Twitter if I want to see horror
you know just drive around Baltimore
cold Deluxe production says you're being
Shadow banned your stream won't show up
at all unless I go to your channel now
YouTube isn't liking you right now and
the YouTube overlords deemed you fake
news Tim just lock your account yeah
it's always been the case though yeah
you know what's crazy I'm willing to
people like how was you know Matt Gates
like how was this show I think it was
Mega it's like how are you still here
and I think it's that they tried Shadow
Banning us but people choose to come and
watch the show and that's organic
viewership you can't algorithmically
erase right they can try and ban us I
guess but then it's just like it
backfires does it ever get better like
you go through periods where you're more
Shadow banned versus less or just to
just continuously get worse over time so
we consistently are the number one live
show in this time slot I mean there's
other other live shows that are big
throughout the week or whatever but we
do a show every Monday through Friday 8
P.M live we rival the numbers of some of
the big networks in terms of key demo
viewership I think YouTube really likes
that they're like look we've got a show
I mean the politics may be an issue but
it's bigger than CNN it's bigger than
MSNBC and it Rivals slightly below Fox
News and key demo viewership and even
sometimes you know we we do well across
the board but Fox gets like 175k in the
key demo we get like 150 so you know
shout out Tucker you know we're not
going to be Tucker I don't think we will
but I think uh if we were going by the
actual proper algorithm we would be
trending every day and so it may be they
removed us from the ability to trend
just because they're like we'd own
trending tab every day for this time
slot but I I think it's more likely it's
just political I my guess is it's it's
not on the trending because it's
political and it becomes the political
network if you go to YouTube and you see
our one showing talking about do other
political shows Trenton though no no no
but but is it is it the pop culture
Network because they have music videos I
mean what like the news is a genre and
this is an entertainment show we're not
this is not it's not a politics show
this is an entertainment show but we we
talk culture and politics like a good
portion of the show we're talking
cultural issues so it's not news and
politics I would love to Trend this show
but I understand as an admin why you're
reticent to put politics anywhere near
the front page you want like Grandma to
come you know be comfortable when she
arrives and not have to be red pilled
that's the idea that means they're
Shadow Banning the show we're
unfortunately Trends on YouTube that I
wouldn't want my grandma to see you know
what I mean like I feel like that we're
not as bad as some of the stuff that
makes the list it's like if you want to
get red pill you got to go look for it I
think maybe that's the admin mindset
because let's let's read this Max Redick
says Tim from any super chats now I've
tried to get you to call people like
Hassan The Young Turks theater etc etc
you finally did it thank you only issue
is I got lit up in the YouTube comments
for thanking you they suggested killing
myself yikes the nasty people so The
Young Turks I did a video where I was
explaining that men and women have
different standards and that as a man if
you compliment another guy's looks in
his outfit and his physique like you've
been working out man like wow that's
like that you're looking pretty good
it's not really that big of a deal some
people might find it weird be like okay
but if you do it to a woman it's just
over the line period like if you went to
a woman and said wow you're looking good
you're working out that's a great outfit
she's going to be like hey please don't
comment on my looks or anything like
that The Young Turks took that clip
where I was quite literally saying you
cannot sexually harass women and then
used it to claim I was arguing you
should be allowed to because it's
equality I don't know I just made it up
I'm missing the this Logic on this one I
think I haven't seen the video or
something okay if you're a guy and you
go to work and you see another guy
you're talking about like in the
workplace this is we're at work
you mentioned Luke was looking ripped
yeah fine as let's just say that now now
say that looking good now what do you
think happens if you would say that
about a female coach I would probably
get extricated from the situation that's
what I hope that's exactly what I said
that you you like Ian were like I saw
Luke you know modeling these eggs and
he's all ripped and looking good and I'm
like damn he's looking good emasculated
me you can't say that I saw this woman
downstairs and he's taking her shirt off
and I'm like oh man she's looking good
oh I'm getting all make me want to have
babies yeah you can't say that like
they're gonna be like yo inappropriate
there's different standards for men and
women So Young Turks took me saying you
can say this to a guy and no one really
cares but you cannot say this to a
minute it's sexual harassment they said
Tim Poole wishes he could sexually
harass women oh so they're assuming
intent they're assuming no no no they're
fabricating it taking the quote out of
context to make it and then telling
people I argued the opposite of what I
argued because they're evil that's not
even clever that's just a lie yeah
that's what they do right that's what
that's what they're saying that's how I
was calling out and then I got pissed
because it's like I make this whole
video saying the military industrial
complex is bad and we shouldn't be
supporting foreign invasions we should
be fixing the pipes in Flint and Newark
and other another cities where kids are
drinking lead we shouldn't be spending
any money on gender studies in Pakistan
was 10 million dollars and then Hassan
insults and divides me and sets its agit
prop for conservatives he says that I'm
supporting capitalism I'm like why can't
he be like okay we agree on this one
let's get Tim Poole to give us his like
to get like let's come together with him
and his his audience and maybe we can
actually get some health care for these
people who are blind because that's what
I'm saying no no his point was
I can't believe he would say that it's
agit prop like why are you deriding me
at all that's the video where he like
got up and went to the bathroom yeah
like while reacting or commentating to
it right like I feel like what he's
trying to say is like get off my side we
can't have anything in common he says I
think people the comments were arguing
that I was trying to trick their
followers and to agreeing with me or
whatever and it's like or wait I'm
literally agreeing with you while you
twist your mustache evil villain here's
how it works it's because
Young Turks will take a video out of
context and then Hassan and others will
react to that fake video
and they'll make up in their minds a
fake version of me because they don't
actually watch this show correct and you
too
you know and that's that's the game they
play because they're cool and so what
what they're doing is and you see this
by the way in a lot of cult psychology
it's sort of this idea of you can't go
and listen to another Outlet because
those people are crazy and and not just
have a difference of opinion but are bad
and are bad for you are toxic or
nightmarish others um this is what some
Cults refer to as a schismatic person or
a suppressive person that
um you must extra to your point to
extricate people from your life what
even if they're a family member who's
simply saying things that they disagree
with because you have to maintain your
audience this is why if you're someone
who has read the New York Times cover to
cover every day for the last six years
imagine how much you've been lied to
imagine haven't you been propagandized
imagine how much you believe about the
world that is completely false but they
keep telling you that people like Jack
pesobic and in pool and Tucker Carlson
Steve bat whatever are are all liars and
crazy tinfoil hat Believers and so you
better not listen so what they're doing
is they're just constantly uh
essentially constantly pimping out their
own audience you know my favorite part
of this was when uh he's reacting to the
video and I said this is why I'm in
favor of some kind of New Deal type
infrastructure rebuilding project in the
US so we could fix the roads and bridges
that are falling apart fill potholes fix
these pipes in places like flint and
that's why when the green New Deal was
announced I was actually really excited
and came out in support of it and then
of course when they actually released
the resolution and it was free college
for people of color I was like I have no
idea what this is and the reaction from
his audience was they were like since
when does Tim Poole support Green New
Deal blah blah blah and I'm like in 2018
five years ago when I made a video
saying the us could could invest in
energy independence with new
technologies like fusion and nuclear
reactors creating jobs we're fixing our
bridges and Roads and I think it's a
better spending of our money than
blowing up kids in Afghanistan since
I've always maintained the position
these people don't actually which by the
way though and and I I keep saying this
is why I I I've decided to really adopt
Darren Beatty's formulation on this so
the globalist American Empire that these
these client states and these endless
Wars don't necessarily exist obviously
for the reason that we're told they
exist they exist as a money wash they
exist as a way to enforce and expand the
authority of the GAE they will always be
looking for some in the IMF the World
Bank they're always going to be looking
for a place where they can conduct what
they call shock therapy and so let's we
got to read more superchargers real
quick on that just to finish the point
if the Tates were looking for a place
that they could operate outside of
scrutiny what do you think our our
leaders are doing that's right all right
Jess bosito says what are your thoughts
on Jordan Peterson announcing on Rogan
that he started an international
Consortium in London to officially
oppose the vision of the world economic
Forum with an alternative that's to be
announced I also love when Hannah Claire
is on I like it but London well that's
weird yeah the the why not El Salvador
yeah I'm not even kidding I'm I'm gonna
say this right now Dr Peterson please El
Salvador I'm not kidding I mean this
absolutely seriously what's going on in
El Salvador is amazing you guys should
follow Max Kaiser and Stacy uh Herbert
Herbert yeah Stacy Herbert Stacey
Herbert I always get her last name on
for some reason but uh follow them
because uh they're awesome they're
they're basically we talked about this
last night and then Max tweeted at me
like we got to come down and do this
show but uh they they gave Bitcoin
everybody crime is dropping the standard
of living is skyrocketing people are
moving down there and this follows in my
my view a vision of freedom
in verse to what Davos is not to mention
the climate is inverse to what davo says
they go there it's winter it's skiing
it's snow El Salvador is you know uh
closer to the Equator it's warmer it's
in uh Central America more fun I think
the right place for this to be Dr
Peterson is El Salvador oh hell yes
seriously I love the idea I was thinking
the other night that we need I believe
we need a World Congress of some sort
that's like an Olympics of the mind that
we can all regardless of who's at war we
can all come together in some level and
talk about bigger things
um and this might be it I I couldn't I
couldn't disagree more I I just I think
that any any attempt I think that when
you name something you give it power I
don't think that I think Shakespeare is
wrong that you know Rose by another
knows uh other name Etc that when you're
talking about a global Consortium or a
World Congress or any of these types of
entities that exist to sort of guide and
give effort to I mean the do you have
things of Brussels in the policies of
Washington are fundamentally different
we are always going to have different
self-interests and so that's fine if you
want to have forums to Hash this stuff
out but the idea of of all of that It
just strikes me as part of the same
neoliberal project a neocom project to
build a One World Government that's been
going on since Woodrow Wilson do you
think it's inevitable that if uh do you
think if we called Rose's snuggle farts
people would still give them to each
other as a sign of romantic gestures
well if you Associated the word snorkel
fart with that no obviously right what
you're saying it makes complete sense
then no you wouldn't want that I would
say sweetheart it's Valentine's Day
here's duplicate of snorkel farts yeah
daisies call them Nazi war crimes and I
bet a lot less
[Laughter]
there there we go
there we are there we are well I think
that the New World Order is appearing
regardless the liberal economic orders
is could be potentially morphed into it
but if we don't it will be bricks will
be morphed into it and we'll be living
under some corporate communist thumb
let's let's read some more Super chats
we got Preston TAMU says your segment
this afternoon about Jim clout Chasers
and years ago similar situations is
precisely why I have serious hesitations
about helping anyone I don't personally
know accusations supersede innocence in
the public eye true it's a video I
talked about where a woman is trying to
squat uh you know too much weight and
she can't get back up and she's looking
around going hey excuse me and there's
guys and they're just like walk they
walk past they don't pay attention
they're not looking and maybe they have
earbuds in I don't know but she's like
sitting there for a good two minutes and
no one helps her until finally a lady
comes up and I guys got to tell you if
I'm a dude she's clearly not in distress
I don't know what she wants I'm gonna
I'm gonna say I'm gonna go to a staff
member and be like she's yelling I don't
know what it's about I will help well
and Jack's first reaction was like do
you think it was a trap do you think she
was trying to say I I do wonder and
maybe it's because I spend too much in
entirely too much time on on Twitter but
the fact that she's not really
vocalizing anything I'm wondering and
I'm just asking the question I'm
accusing but I'm wondering if was this
potentially done as a social experiment
because she was just like hey
hey she wasn't loud she was like hello
hey can you come over here and she
wasn't like loud or is she assuming
because she's been told over and over
again when you go to the gym men stare
at you constantly you can't get away
from them staring at you that like she
just assumed men were looking at her and
therefore they would notice her like
that seems like arrogance to me
should I say this so are we no I'm just
going to say it fine
um are we really supposed to so let's
say it's not a social experiment so
you're filming yourself because you know
you're filming a thirst trap this is
obviously a third strap this is like
skin tight she's wearing skin type pants
at a gym she's she's doing that she's
feeling it from that angle because she
wants to post it later on Tick Tock or
Instagram or whatever it is and we have
this whole economy set up based on
thirst trapping and yet we're supposed
to say that even though it's totally
fine for her to do that and we allow
that like if you're gonna set up a new
gym why not say no thirst trapping in
the gym what about that would that be
like what do you do like women have to
wear nikobs or something like if you
want to wear skin tight pants do it no
don't talk about the filming of it yeah
the actual filming of it to then right
she's checking her she's checking your
forms you don't know what you like
you're accusing her if they're strapping
one really she's just trying to get
better exactly this logic can just go on
and on and on I mean no this is
obviously and the problem is that we
have a low trust Society now because
we've destroyed our communities we
become overly litigious we punish people
for just simply what we used to call
doing the right thing or using common
sense and this is the reason that
something like that if that were true
that somebody could be hurt somebody
could be killed because when we think
well you can't this is why you go on
Septa and there will be women getting
raped on a Septa train outside of
Philadelphia and nobody does anything
yeah we've got to be more Super chats we
got uh bad B says guys how long after
the Spanish Flu did world war did the
World War start that's how long until
the next world war starts I'm pretty
sure it was after this it was after the
start yeah we don't know yeah that's
right it was after this it was because
of World War One and the returning right
they were coming back and they had the
the have you seen some of the that
footage of the trenches out in uh in in
eastern Ukraine right now
we're dropping the grenades into him and
stuff well I just mean even it's the
same thing
because and I think Elon even made this
point that tanks in general are kind of
becoming obsolete if you have drones and
precision targeting then a tank is just
a steel a steel coffin this is very
important guys it brings us back to
trench warfare Isaac says vitamin C is
in pine needles there is more vitamin C
in a Christmas tree than in an orchard
of oranges very true what for real hire
that guy so how many do you need to eat
like how do you do you like mash them
and then eat them or like grind them
into things maybe like granola oh you
boil the pine needles in make a tea I
think that's just smoking man just smoke
that smoke then you take too long yeah
like that cuts down on the vitamin C I
could be wrong yeah there's only one way
to find out
all right James moaning says Jack great
to see you what's your favorite Psalm I
like Psalm 10. blessings to you and the
timcast family
uh I'm Catholic I go with whatever one
the mass tells us there you go simple
answer
all right Charles says how are chickens
going to save our society sure I'd love
to move away but how can we my children
are suffering that's my fault due to my
past how do they survive what should I
do we started this not them still
waiting on the app the app is happening
we've got it there's like a rudimentary
version it works like we're just working
on it
um you know watching 1883 was really
enlightening
how did people survive literally in the
middle of nowhere with nothing I'm so
glad you watched it that's exactly what
I thought watching it like it's crazy to
think that to get to Oregon people had
to cross completely Uncharted land with
nothing and just hope that they would
get there right try their best by the
way no but here's the thing too every
Millennial knows exactly what it takes
to cross the Oregon Trail I think that
video game made it seem too easy and
they often talk about how hard it was to
cross a river but they never talk about
getting wagons through a forest right
what would you do when you came to a
forest yeah would you just go around it
you try maybe go under it maybe through
the trees I try and follow the trail
yeah but there was no Trail before the
trail and you're trying that'd be a good
movie called before the trail that a
wagon can go through though and you're
trying to re-race all of the elements
right like you have to get there before
winter and everything with the Donner
Expedition it's crazy little to no water
I mean how much pain were they in too
because we the history books don't talk
about the daily amounts of pain I think
that I was talking to a buddy about this
recently because we were talking about
the history of the Rosary and it's a
long story but I think one thing that we
discount in modern society is just how
much how much of your day how many hours
a day that people would just spend
walking because that was predominantly
the only way you could get from one
point to another really before horses
too that uh or or you know if you
couldn't afford horses before horses
um that you people just walk for hours
and hours a day yeah and this was a
pretty common life until maybe very very
very recently I used to walk New York
Manhattan man you ever do that you were
walking like 40th Street down to the
down to Battery Park or anything like
that yeah well and you know in the city
when I lived in Shanghai you know one
thing about living in a police state
that
um it is always safe to walk across
Shanghai it could be three in the
morning and you could walk from the bond
all the way to jongshan park and you'll
be perfectly fine you would probably not
walk from Washington DC to Harper's
Ferry
several hundred years ago I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry you would probably not
walk it in a day is what I meant to say
no it's a 17 hour walk and so you're
probably gonna walk if you're walking
non-stop 10 hours and then stop and make
Camp that's a two day right there yep
45 hour minute drive for us yeah yeah
hour when you read like Jane Austen like
Jane Austen novels will talk about like
these you know you go out you walk to
your neighbor's house but then there's a
rainstorm and it already took you all
day to get there so you just stay this
is someone you live near this is a
feature in The Song of Ice and Fire
novels That Game of Thrones is based on
that
um you people say well there's whole
chapters and chapters where nothing's
happening because they're just walking
and his point is well no that's that's
what it was like I tried to do a d d
campaign like that my buddy I was like
he was born in this Arctic Village and
he had to get out he was gonna get out
so I gave him an easy way you could wait
for the train he's like I'm gonna walk I
was like all right roll
the 16. all right you take one damage
from cold you walk for five minutes roll
and I was like this is gonna be boring
as hell
Andrew ho says Tim they have a signed
receipt of drop-off by Hunter Biden
bongino shows it all the time that's
right they have the receipt that's right
he signed it his dude's out of his mind
but that was forged we all know that oh
okay okay all right x-rayed says Jack
what advice do you have for a veteran
who has opted not uh to not re-enlist
because what the military has become I'd
love to be a part of TP USA
um I would I would honestly suggest
reenlists if if if you're interested if
you want to get out you want to get out
a million ways to contact us contact
turning point but I I do think that in
general we need people that are still in
there we need good people in there you
need people in high positions of
authority so maybe when uh when the Don
comes he can get rid of some of these
really awful high-level uh
administrators and Generals or whatever
that's certainly the plan and and just
to put it out there that given
everything that we've talked about I
really do think there's only one
chess player or chess piece on the board
that could solve all of these things
that we're talking about specifically
the the War and Peace World War III
problems yeah only one person that is
not beholden to these things Bill Hughes
says part of my family is Irish they
were oppressed and discriminated against
for being the wrong race and religion
you know I'm also Irish oh me too me too
I think you know we uh we need free
money from the government that's the
only way for that you know it's only
forced to fight in World War excuse me
Civil War that's right um both sides in
some cases you know it's a replacement
for that's right I'm the child of
immigrants I feel like I need some kind
of compensation our country is not
you're basically a refugee I basically I
am a refugee yeah yeah all right let's
see what we got here and we'll grab some
more uh here's a good one Donald Duval
says I stand behind Alec Baldwin and the
joke is I I stand behind Alec Baldwin
because you stand in front of me might
get shot
oh that's so brutal all right everybody
if you haven't already uh actually let's
uh we'll read one more Frump says weird
I have to pay to say this but I have not
received an Amber Alert in three years
they used to be annoying but that was
weird all right
wait okay that is a good setting turn
that's on your phone if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends become a
member at timcast.com because we're
going to have a members only uncensored
show coming up for you in about one hour
so go to timcast.com click join us and
you can sign up with a huge library of
content cast Castle funny skits where we
make fun of cultural political issues
and we do sketches that kind of you know
you know poke fun and uh of course the
Tim cast iron uncensored members show
which we're gonna have up for you
tonight you can follow the show at
timcastirl you can follow me personally
at timcast Jack you want to shout
anything out uh gonna be at mines Fest
coming up tax day uh April 15th down in
Austin very excited I think you're going
to be down yeah and we're at four right
the day before we're doing IRL live
we're sold out but you should come down
for sure let's do it yeah um check that
out I think it's minds.com
festival.minds.com and of course for
anyone who is going to be staying up to
wait for that third hour that third
uncensored special I know you have to
wait another hour I know you're gonna be
tired I know you're going to to feel how
can I sleep how can I get through the
next day there's so much happening the
threat of nuclear war Looms on the
horizon ladies and gentlemen Mike
Lindell has been working on a top secret
project it's even more top secret than
the documents that Joe Biden has in his
underpants this is my pillow too it just
dropped it has been released to the
worlds revealed to us in our time of
need mypillow.com promo code Pozo Jack
Faso because the other my pillow guy yes
uh I'm Hannah club remlo I'm a writer
for timcast.com you should follow at
timcast news on Twitter and you should
also follow Tim cast news on Instagram
uh newly launched today I believe so go
check that out you can follow me
personally at hannahclair.b on Instagram
and you can follow me on Twitter at HC
brimlow thanks so much I also will be at
the mines Fest in Austin April 15th is
festival.minds.com you are right jack
with sobic see you there man yeah I'll
see you on stage we should have a debate
on something we should talk about God
and Christianity and religion and maybe
let it Let It Fly and go to a lot us I
have in the past go again I would be
open to that I would go with you keep
going so basically we're doing it's it's
it's it's two separate events basically
we have Tim cast IRL live Friday night
at the Vulcan and then the next day the
mines Festival so it's like two two same
venue yeah and uh we're all hanging out
with each other basically a Love Fest in
the world yeah I think it's fantastic
if you're not from Austin and you really
want to come see the show you've got an
opportunity to see two different shows
you make a whole weekend out of it so
I'm excited it should be very cool and
it will be very cool also if we can get
Mike Lindell to thread some graphene
into one of his upcoming pillows I'd be
really into it this jacket has there's
only there's only so many things I can
talk about here on the open show but for
the members show we'll get into it's
gonna get dark it's gonna get hot and
then it's gonna get light again
okay hey surge nice hat hey yeah I wore
the the Hat I've been wearing for a
while I haven't I haven't worn it in
like probably Uh Oh I thought that was
so funny yeah it's funny it's because I
wore it in the beginning and I stopped
wearing it for a little bit uh where
that like FC didn't didn't Epstein
himself hat and then uh I brought it
back for old times and it's true the
ball on the head is so Sailors when they
were under the deck when they lifted
their head they didn't bump their head
on the wood yeah apparently I think they
like I think they like they re they took
that from the old Scandinavian tradition
of just palming the hat but anyways I'm
at surge.com on Twitter I'm arguing with
a lot of people there I kind of get
Twitter now but uh yeah all right all
right everybody we will see you all over
at timcast.com thanks for hanging out
cheers